the desert is still
the night seems endless silent and at
peace
until it's pierced by the sound of
gunshots and screams
deep in the sahara the scp foundation is
waging war against a newly discovered
enemy a squad of foundation agents is
retreating trying to get away from the
ones who massacred their allies
they were attempting to eliminate the
threat using conventional means but
their rifles were no match for the
reality-bending entities of the kingdom
of abaddon the retreating agents cover
one another as they make their way back
to the extraction point the enemy force
advances agents that are caught too
close to the sorcerers of abaddon
disintegrated to thin air this is not an
enemy they can defeat the scp agents
need to get back to base and relay what
they have found to their superiors
out of the hundreds of agents sent into
the sahara that night only a handful
make it out alive they are debriefed by
their superiors at the foundation who
classified the anomalous humanoids under
the highest of threat levels the kingdom
of abaddon is a threat
the kingdom of abaddon must be
eliminated reconnaissance done prior to
the disastrous mission had alerted the
foundation to the presence of anomalies
in the region but they had no idea how
strong the anomalous humanoids would be
from data gathered through old reports
it seemed like the abaddon humanoids
were responsible for the deaths of no
fewer than 75 foundation personnel and
had stolen at least 12 different items
from the foundation
the leaders of the scp foundation tasked
research team omega-5 with developing a
weapon that would be capable of
destroying the kingdom of abaddon once
and for all the weapon they are
researching must be capable of
long-range destruction because the
moment any foundation agent gets close
to the area they are vaporized by the
reality manipulating powers of its
inhabitants the project is given the
name twins of god and is led by a
foundation doctor known only by the
designation
o51 051 is popular in the scp foundation
well known for his in-depth research and
charismatic personality making him the
perfect person to lead such a project
and o51 recently came across an anomaly
that he believes holds the solution the
foundation has been looking for to
defeat the kingdom of abaddon item001
and so the omega 5 team gets to work
they discover that the anomaly has
incredible powers when put inside a host
which they refer to as an item001 entity
and set up a series of experiments using
different people to harness its energy
the first series of tests all end in
tragedy the anomaly causes the entity it
inhabits to become intensely radioactive
anyone who gets close to it succumbs to
immediate radiation sickness and
eventually death to stop the radiation
problems the omega-5 research group
intensifies the containment procedures
o51 receives reports from the higher-ups
that the kingdom of abaddon has attacked
another foundation facility in sudan
long-range defenses needed asap the
administrator puts more pressure on
omega 5 and especially its leader 051 to
solve the problems of item 01 and
develop a weapon that can save the
foundation he stays awake for days on
end working tirelessly to create a safe
and controllable item001 entity although
there are signs that the weapon will
work it is still unpredictable when
item001 is initiated the host entity
becomes paralyzed suffers severe
cerebral hemorrhaging and soon a new
host is needed before testing can begin
again and that's not the only thing that
goes wrong
whenever the anomaly is put into a new
host sudden and random destruction of
on-site structures and personnel take
place o51 knows though that if this
power can be harnessed and controlled in
the right way that it could be the
weapon that the foundation needs to wipe
out the kingdom of abaddon once and for
all in order to control item001 o51 has
a mine kill switch implanted in its
host's brains o51 can activate the
implant to incapacitate its host and
immediately stop the unwanted
destruction countless hosts are
terminated by this mind kill switch in
the early trials conducted by the omega
5 team but progress continues to be made
and eventually a hypothesis is
formulated perhaps the disastrous side
effects of item 001 can be offset by
spreading the anomaly across multiple
subjects they theorize that the immense
mental load of the anomaly can be
distributed among several hosts thus
reducing the toil it takes on each and
giving them the ability to control its
immense power but o51 and the omega-5
team need more data and for that they
need more bodies they consult with the
director of site 17 and it is concluded
that the nearby town of san marco would
be an appropriate place to get the
additional test subjects they require on
a quiet sunday morning omega-5 along
with support from a squad of armed scp
agents storm into the san marcos de la
vida sterna church during the middle of
mass they gather up a number of the
younger congregants and bring them back
to the site where item 001 is housed
the researchers quickly ran through
their new supply of test subjects though
and omega 5 would need to get even more
if their research was to continue
instead of going back and forth between
the testing facility and san marcos 051
decided to move the entire item 001
operation to the town itself he renames
the town testing site 001 and omega 5
rounds up 23 of the healthiest subjects
they can find for use in the next series
of research tests a few weeks after
occupying the town of san marco omega-5
makes its most substantial progress yet
just as they theorized by spreading out
the anomaly of item 01 across a specific
group of hosts they can control its
powers the test may have cost the lives
of almost everyone in the town
but the ends certainly justify the means
the kingdom of abaddon poses an
existential threat to the scp foundation
after all and thanks to this research
they will soon have a weapon capable of
bringing them victory the foundation
administer criticized o51's methods but
can't argue with his results
unfortunately o51 has a dark secret a
secret that disturbs even the most
hardened and loyal members of omega-5 a
secret that has to do with the item001
hosts the host that omega-5 has made its
major progress with are not the ordinary
test subjects normally used by the
foundation no the test subjects o51
makes his breakthrough with our children
nine of them to be exact all between
four and eleven years old despite being
told specifically by the foundation
administrator to only test on adults the
research required o51 to break the chain
of command and follow the science down
the path of lead the children are
contained in a reinforced bunker where
only 051 and a select few have access
they are technically alive but are
functionally brain dead the group of
nine children share a hive mind that can
process information and more importantly
can unleash the full potential of the
implanted anomaly creating and
controlling a devastating power
but not everyone is thrilled with what
they've achieved members of omega 5 are
haunted by the screams of the children
that they forced to be part of their
weapons development program they
describe their merging with item 001 as
being a process that rips out their
souls and replaces them with something
much more sinister
in fact all of omega five regret what
they have been a part of
and what they've done
all except oh five one the nine children
can channel unprecedented amounts of
energy from an unknown origin that
omega-5 hypothesizes comes from an
extra-dimensional source which is then
used to unbind atoms at the quantum
level when the right activation words
are spoken it appears as though this
tremendous power gives the children the
ability to annihilate anything in the
entire universe it's a gun to end all
guns and only o51 has the key to control
it the nine children work so well with
an item001 that omega-5 reclassifies it
to include the nine children themselves
they are not just the entity housing or
controlling item001 they permanently
become item001
once omega-5 has a better understanding
of item 001 they begin to run tests to
find out the full extent of its
abilities
first they test the distance item 001
can reach the initial test that omega-5
carries out is on a steel rod placed
five kilometers away o51 orders the
children to destroy the target moments
later the phone next to o51 begins to
ring when he picks it up the observer
tasked with watching the pole is on the
other end he informs 0-5-1 that the
steel rod has been completely vaporized
051 is not satisfied though he has
another pole sent out this time placed 8
000 kilometers away from the nine
children o51 asks the children to
destroy that rod almost immediately the
phone rings again the target has been
vaporized
051 smiles
the next series of tests omega 5 runs on
item001 are to determine the maximum
size of an object that can be destroyed
the tests start out with a steel sphere
three meters in diameter placed one
thousand kilometers from item 001 051
orders the children to destroy the
object it is instantly vaporized o51 has
seen enough small tests it's time for
something big
so he does something that will later be
questioned by everyone at the scp
foundation he orders the nine children
to destroy a church of the broken god
worship site in turkey
not long after the destruction order is
given to item 001 reports begin coming
in the worship site has been obliterated
with no observable damage to the
surrounding area
deadly and precise
o51 closes his eyes and takes a deep
breath he looks as if he's overcome by
an immense spiritual experience he opens
his eyes leans over to the children and
whispers the name of something
later that day o51 finds out that the
target he had named has been vaporized
the success of omega 5 in item001 is
relayed to the administration of the
foundation they are so impressed that
they make plans to use item001 to
eliminate the abaddon threat once and
for all however one of the heads of the
foundation administrator williams has
major concerns about the way 0-5-1 is
running the program the updates that
0-5-1 has been sending have become less
scientific
and more
philosophical
more
spiritual administrator williams sends a
letter to o51 reassuring him that he is
doing good work but once the mission to
destroy the kingdom of avadon is
completed o51 will be promoted to
director and reassigned to the newly
constructed site-19 for the good of the
foundation and maybe the rest of the
world he'll be permanently moved away
from item001
051's response is short and to the point
i am fine administrator the project is
finished
we will complete our task when you
arrive
administrator williams arrives at
site-001 a few days later he is greeted
by o51 and the omega-5 team
williams can't help but notice that
0-5-1 has a strange look in his eyes it
is the look of a crazed man who has been
lost in his work and who has perhaps
lost himself
williams puts the thought away though
and walks with o51 and his accompanying
agents to the viewing area where the
powers of item zero zero one will be
demonstrated
administrator williams and the other
agents want from a protected viewing
room as o51 enters the chamber of his
new super weapon
it's time to see if their weapon that
has had so much time effort sweat tears
and especially blood poured into it will
have been worth it
everyone watches as o51 leans over and
says the name of the abaddon citadel to
the nine children
all at once they start to glow no one
observing can see what has happened in
the far-off kingdom but they know
something big has happened the
administrator is thrilled but notices
something
0-5-1 hesitated the moment while leaning
over the children before standing back
up
did he whisper something else to them
and then administrator williams
vaporizes pulled apart at an atomic
level before he has the chance to scream
what's going on the agent standing next
to where administrator williams
previously existed began to yell and
pull out their guns they burst through
the door of the observation room and run
down the hallway towards where 0-5-1 and
the 9 children are located the armed
agents rush into the room but 0-5-1 is
gone
nine children are still
over the next few weeks o51 is reported
to be seen several times by scp agents
however no one is able to catch him and
it appears as though other members of
the scp foundation have also gone awol
as well perhaps joining him on the run
it is unclear what his plan is but the
reports from the reconnaissance team
sent into the sahara make it obvious
what the result of his first command to
the children was
there isn't a single humanoid or
building left in the kingdom of abaddon
but even with this victory the highest
levels of the scp foundation have an
ominous thought lurking in the back of
their minds
where did o51 go and what is he planning
to do next
following the improper use of item 001
leading to the untimely death of a
high-ranking foundation staff member
the weapon was deemed too dangerous and
containment procedures were implemented
due to the high amount of radiation they
were found to emit the nine children
were placed into lead-lined bags and
buried under 50 meters of concrete
beneath the church of san marcos de la
vida eterna
though all the children continued to be
functionally brain-dead they still
display signs of life despite their
containment
and by order of the overseer council
have been classified as a thaumial
entity
it's a quiet evening at area 11 where
the pietro cow fountain spatial
stabilization array is housed a skeleton
crew is working overnight to ensure the
array is ready for its big test the
following day the foundation has been
working on a particle accelerator that
will contain anomalies with the ability
to manipulate the nature of space-time
the preliminary tests seem promising but
a few last-minute tweaks to the array
are necessary unfortunately it is on
this night in 1982 that marks the
beginning of the end for the scp
foundation dr calvin desmond is
monitoring the array and he notices as
it spools up that there is some minor
power fluctuation in one of the
stabilization arms this problem is not
uncommon due to the vast amounts of
energy being pumped through the array
and the harmonic resonance the machine
gives off which slowly causes the
coupling rings to loosen calvin desmond
decides that remounting the
stabilization rings will be an easy fix
and it's a necessary one he knows that
if the rings fail during the actual test
the array could end up shut down for
months there is still plenty of time so
calvin desmond grabs his toolbox and
heads down to the array the machine is
still spooling keeping the energy
flowing at a constant low rate there is
no danger at the moment as the inside of
the array is shielded from the radiation
and energy pulsing through the outer
ring but then something unexpected
happens the system's primary generator
begins to fluctuate uncontrollably a
catastrophic failure is imminent sirens
begin to sound the facility is evacuated
and the chamber is sealed deep in the
bowels of the array calvin desmond
cannot hear the evacuation announcement
the humming of the array echoes through
the chamber dampening all sound from the
outside world the array begins to come
online while desmond continues to work
on the coupling he has no idea what is
about to happen meanwhile a team of
foundation scientists scramble to get
the power fluctuations in the main
generator under control as they
frantically work catastrophe strikes
they initiate the power down cycle but
as the generator struggles to keep the
power flow balanced an energy surge
builds up a massive amount of energy is
released all at once causing the main
reactor to explode the entire structure
rocks back and forth and desmet is
thrown into the side of the array he too
now knows that something is very wrong
and runs for the exit when he reaches
the door he finds that has been sealed
in a panic desmond continues running
through the tube to the next access
point this door has been locked as well
he's never been so scared in his entire
life and he shakes uncontrollably from
the adrenaline being dumped into his
muscles the surge of energy rushes
through the array towards desmond a
singularity begins to form in the
containment chamber the array is working
just as it should except that there was
never supposed to be a person inside as
the singularity was brought into
existence moments after the singularity
forms the massive pull of its gravity
causes the stabilizer arm that desmond
had been working on to fail the sight of
the array is ripped off and calvin
desmond stares into the naked eye of the
singularity everything is silent and
still for a moment then the singularity
collapses in on itself taking the test
chamber and much of the research wing
with it along with dr calvin desmond
sparking wires hang from the exposed
walls and ceiling where the singularity
rips the main structure away water flows
into the deep hole carved out of the
earth where the array once stood the
scientists from area 11 look into the
crater left by the collapse singularity
the foundation administration sends
agents to collect the staff at the site
and document the failings of the project
they conclude that the accident was
caused by human error they ordered the
array to be rebuilt this time using
entirely automated systems to eliminate
the chances of another mishap occurring
several years after the catastrophic
events at area 11 a new array is
constructed an intelligent system called
netzac is put in charge of overseeing
its functions it is a supercomputer that
is programmed to follow commands but can
autonomously make decisions in order to
prevent any failures in the system
experiments begin again in may of 2006.
the new array soon manifests its first
singularity in the containment chamber
at area 11 and what happens next will
forever change the foundation and the
multiverse the singularity is kept
stable in the array it seems as if the
foundation has succeeded in trapping and
containing spatial anomalies but as they
run more diagnostics on the anomaly
something unexpected happens the
singularity begins to grow in size the
point of infinite gravity threatens to
breach containment as it reaches the
boundaries of the array just before
contact the singularity's growth slows
and then stops netsac has made the
split-second calculations and
adjustments necessary to contain the
singularity the artificial intelligence
has saved the facility and the lives of
everyone in it now sitting in the array
is a thick rotating cloud of radioactive
gas and dust obscuring the singularity
within as foundation scientists work
rapidly to fix the array odd events
begin to occur the workers hear noises
that sound like painful wailing over
time the noises evolve into words and
then full sentences they seem to be
originating from the singularity using
equipment able to penetrate the thick
cloud of radioactive gas the foundation
scientists get a glimpse at the
singularity to their surprise the
singularity has taken on the shape of a
human the scientists work frantically to
figure out how the singularity could
have formed itself into a humanoid shape
dr j barton ramsay is the first to try
and make contact with the humanoid
within the singularity he finds that the
entity cannot communicate in the
traditional sense the massive
gravitational pull of the singularity
does not allow sound to escape its void
instead the entity manipulates gravity
to vibrate the suspension rings of the
array itself and create sound waves the
being in the singularity whispers in a
metallic voice created by the vibrating
of the array's rings and says johannes
ramsey dr ramsey steps back from the
observation window how do you know my
name he asked the entity the humanoid
within the swirling gas cloud identifies
itself as having the memories of calvin
desmond it is not desmet per se the
being in the singularity is so much more
than one person but it was somehow
created by the accident that had sucked
calvin desmond into the singularity
years before the entity seems to switch
between the mind of desmond and the vast
infinity of the cosmos the desmond
entity asks for an overseer from the
foundation to be brought in it has a
proposal for the o5 council when dr
ramsay asks why the entity needs to talk
to the overseers it replies that it
wants to offer them away
the following day o51 enters the
facility and heads to the observation
deck he looks through the reinforced
glass at the swirling cloud of
radioactive dust then glances at the
monitor to see the humanoid shape of the
singularity within he presses the
microphone button on the console and
addresses the entity to whom am i
speaking he asks for simplicity's sake
the entity tells o5-1 to refer to him as
calvin desmond 05-1 makes notes of the
events unfolding before him and then
asks about the way out that calvin had
mentioned the error is still for a
moment then desmond begins to speak
through the vibration of the structure
once again he informs o5-1 that what the
scp foundation is doing by securing and
containing anomalous entities around the
world is like putting a small band-aid
on a much bigger wound desmond wants to
propose a final solution to all of the
foundation's problems o5-1 listens
intently as the entity unravels the
mysteries of where the scps have come
from he explains that the anomalies that
the foundation has worked so hard to
secure contain and protect the human
race from are actually bleeding into
their reality from a vast multiverse the
only way to stop the manifestation of
anomalies into this universe is to
destroy all other realities the entity
that is calvin desmond tells o5-1 that
he is able to bring about this
destruction
if they release him from the confines of
the array 05-1 is transfixed by the
swirling gas that is promising him and
everyone else on earth salvation he
shakes his head in disbelief could this
be true o5-1 turns away from the
swirling gas and begins to walk away
from the viewing glass i'll need to
think about what you're saying the
structure begins to shake slightly the
voice of calvin desmond reverberates off
of the array a little louder than before
choose quickly overseer although it
won't happen for decades eventually a
catastrophic scp event will wipe out
life on this planet perhaps not in your
lifetime but it will most certainly
happen within the lifetime of your
children
we will talk again soon
the vibrations slow and then stop
completely there is an eerie stillness
in the observation room as o5-1 walks
out the next day all staff members
located at area 11 are relocated to
other foundation sites and given
amnestics the o5 council meets in a
large circular room with wood paneling
and no windows oh 5-1 begins the meeting
by telling the others what calvin
desmond had described about the end of
the world he pauses for what seems like
an eternity and tells them of desmond's
offer that he could prevent the end of
the world but at the cost of destroying
an infinite number of other realities
this would mean that all the humans and
creatures of those realities would be
destroyed as well was murdering
countless other beings worth it to
protect their own reality 05-1 begins to
shake he hasn't slept or eaten anything
since his talk with desmond he's being
torn apart from the inside oh 5-3 stands
up and addresses the council he informs
everyone in the room that independent
teams have concluded research into what
the calvin desmond entity has claimed
and they found it to be true the world
really would come to an end furthermore
the research teams determined that the
capabilities of desmond would in fact
allow him to dismantle the other
realities 05-3 insists that the council
must vote to allow desmond to destroy
the other realities to ensure that this
reality could be saved they must strike
now before the world is overrun 05-1
continues to shake while o5-3 breathes
heavily sweat pouring down his temples
the rest of the council shifts their
gazes from side to side it is time for a
vote there are eight eyes to allow
desmond to destroy all other realities
and four nays against the plan 05-3
stands up and walks around the room
stopping behind each nay voter and
putting a bullet in their head he stops
at the last 05-9
who pulls out a gun places it under her
own chin and pulls the trigger 05-13
abstains from the vote and the measure
passes the remaining overseers will use
the calvin desmond entity to save their
reality at the expense of all others and
they soon head to area 11 to execute
their plan 05-1 4 and 12 enter the
observation room that looks upon the
swirling radioactive gas around calvin
desmond 05-1 orders netzak to begin
powering down the array which will allow
the entity to prove he can do what he
has promised they have pinpointed the
reality that scp-884 came from and the
shaving mirror itself sits on a table in
another room in the facility o5-3 stands
in the room watching the mirror to see
if anything happens 05-1 asks calvin
desmond to eliminate the reality that
the mirror had come from the room shakes
as the entity uses it to acknowledge the
request moments later the phone rings in
the observation room it is 05-3 he
informs the others that the mirror has
disappeared its reality has been
destroyed and therefore it no longer
exists there is a sigh of relief in the
room as the overseers realize that this
just might work 05-1 asks calvin desmond
to continue and destroy all the
realities that are bleeding into their
own this time the entire facility begins
to quake suddenly 05-1 jerks backwards
his eyes wide in confusion and horror
his body seems to be compressing under
an unknown force o5-1 begins to distort
his legs and arms fold into the core of
his body his head snaps down and all
that was 05-1 is sucked down into a
single point in space before it
completely disappears calvin desmond
then turns his attention to the other
two overseers in the room who both seem
to collapse into black holes of their
own in the center of their bodies
netsack's warning klaxon begins to sound
signaling that the emergency failsafe
has been activated before calvin desmond
is brought under control the structural
support in the entire facility vibrates
with his words they are in a voice that
sounds strangely similar to o51s your
children are free to live lives that do
not end in horror an end to your
perpetual struggle an end to darkness
the freedom to live in the light all
traces must
be removed this world must be washed
clean the foundation does not escape
atonement it is the only way out it had
been a deception the calvin desmond
entity had no intention of stopping
anomalies from infiltrating this world
it wanted to remove all traces of the
anomalous from all universes including
this one and that meant destroying the
overseers and the foundation itself
their destruction would serve as an
atonement for the pain and suffering
they had caused in their quest to secure
and contain the anomalous calvin had to
lie to the overseers about the real plan
since he knew they'd never sacrificed
themselves and the foundation even if it
meant an end to the anomalies plaguing
our world now though with the overseers
out of the way the calvin desmond entity
is free to move forward with its plan
and purge all realities of any trace of
the anomalous but just then netsach's
failsafes kick in and the petrikau
fountain spatial stabilization array
subdues the entity's abilities desmet is
once again contained 05-3 bursts through
the door and into the observation room
he stands before the shattered glass of
the window that looks into the array o53
asks netsack how long the containment
array can hold calvin desmet the
computer's voice fades in and out but
says given current conditions
119 days 6 hours and 47 minutes 05-3
sighs he tells netsack to make a node in
the scp database that the calvindesmith
entity will now be known as scp-001
then to make dozens of other randomly
generated entries and label them as
scp-001 as well he knows that they will
need to keep the true nature of what
this entity can do with secret oh 5-3
walks out of the room under his breath
he speaks to himself they'll say that
i'll know the one true god when i see it
and to give that god everything it wants
because that's the only thing that
matters tonight it appears god wants to
talk to me
you can attempt to flee you can try your
best to hide you might even valiantly
try to fight back but when the bloody
dawn of the scarlet king finally
stretches across the multiverse's
collective horizon there will be almost
nothing that we can do every sadistic
monster every world ending horror every
dimension transcending malicious reality
warper none of them even begin to
approach the danger and pure undiluted
evil of the crimson khan himself we've
covered this horrific eldritch entity in
several videos before from his scp-001
proposal to the potential scp identities
of his hellish spawn to the earthly
vectors of those children the horrifying
scp-231
but today we're not interested in once
again going over how the scp foundation
feels about their greatest enemy that's
only one side of the story today we're
going to explore the origins of the
scarlet king through the cold dark eyes
of a very different source his very
first earthly worshippers it all began
with the
we've discussed this extinct culture
before on this channel in passing but to
fully understand how we know the cursed
information we're imparting today we
first need to understand exactly who the
devites are and why they were such a
terrifying society we're not talking
about a mere group of interest here like
the serpent's hand or the chaos
insurgency we're talking about an
imperialistic militarist civilization
that brought pain terror and suffering
to everyone and everything they
encountered the device culture was
arranged into a series of dense urban
city-states that supported themselves
through brutal slave labor farmed from
their own people and weaker groups that
they conquered through extremely hostile
takeovers the name devites is derived
from the culture's ruling class the
devas powerful and potentially immortal
sorcerers who maintain their abilities
through ritualistic torture sacrifice
and cannibalism much of what we know
about these monsters is derived from a
cursed book titled a chronicle of the
devas designated by the foundation as
scp-140 an incomplete chronicle much
like its subjects the book is
bloodthirsty ink or human blood spilled
around the book will be stolen and
incorporated into text on its sorted
pages that would be ominous enough but
it gets much worse as editions of the
book are revised through these sanguine
updates the book literally revises the
history of the real world moving the
extinction date of the davites just that
much closer the book is one of the
foundation's most closely guarded
anomalies because if enough revisions
are made that the device culture enters
recent history or even worse the present
day it would mean the end of the world
as we know it in all likelihood the
lucky ones among us would be killed or
written out of history immediately the
rest would become slaves to the devas or
become victims to their occult bloodlust
after finding out all this about these
horrifying people it really shouldn't
come as a surprise to you that they're
some of the first recorded worshipers of
the scarlet king in our dimension you'd
have trouble finding a more perfect
representation of the king's philosophy
around pain cruelty subjugation and a
world ruled by primitive violence that
brings us to what we can learn about the
king himself from artifacts left behind
by his first and most ardent followers a
collection of tablets that act as a kind
of sacred holy creation myth for the
scarlet king and this gruesome pantheon
was discovered at a foundation-sponsored
devite dig site and using other devite
sources these tablets were translated
into a harrowing account known only as
dust and blood between the darkness
below and the darkness above at the
beginning of all things the tree of life
was planted this was the moment when all
things across the multiverse were given
form life and death began expansion and
entropy order and chaos and out of all
of that a cast of elder gods were also
born into the vast and quivering dark
many of their names have been lost to
the pages of history but one that was
not was a being known only as kaharak
kaharok was born into humble beginnings
he and his forgotten siblings roiled in
the abyss the only thing separating him
from everything else being the very
awareness that he was struck down in the
abyss he was both blessed and cursed
with self-awareness in a void filled
with ignorant darkness he felt the sting
of loneliness pain and resentment and if
existence was such pain what was the
point of existing at all in fact what
was the point of anyone or anything
existing if they were all just doomed to
this dull suffering at this moment
kahrak found his calling bringing about
the end of everything but first he
needed strength to achieve this he
devoured his brothers and sisters in the
abyss stealing their strength and their
essence this is known as the first sin
of kahrak and he was punished
accordingly with even greater pain as he
grew and of course this did nothing but
strengthen his resolve blinded by pain
fury and pure hatred he vowed to uproot
and destroy the very tree of life itself
for putting him through this awfulness
this was kahrak's first bloody conquest
he clawed his way up to his throne
slaying and devouring countless other
elder gods over eons of brutality and
war some were allowed to live for
showing loyalty to kha'rok and they
would amass great power under him but it
would only ever be under him he was
beginning to form what would later
become his legion of terrifying
supernatural warriors and servants when
his conquest of the lower realms of
creation was complete he gave himself
the title of king of the darkness below
he also took the name kinth higor to
reflect his new position his kingdom of
absolute cruelty and despair would claim
the souls of anyone unlucky enough to
stray too close and put them through the
suffering that kintigor had so resented
but his work wasn't done he was just
getting started the king of the darkness
below declared all-out war on the rest
of creation opening the floodgates and
releasing his terrifying forces on the
surrounding kingdoms their operations
were the template for the davide way of
warfare and life they would conquer and
destroy and force the survivors into
servitude anyone who dared defy the
orders of the king would be broken and
destroyed his word was law and the law
was absolute at some point during the
expansion of his empire kinthi gore
enslaved a wise and beautiful goddess
known as sana or the mother of those
beneath us she detested the king and his
seemingly limitless barbarism but she
was smart enough to follow his orders
and feign loyalty to ensure her
continued survival in the short term
this however would not ensure her safety
forever kintigor had no intention of
ruling and conquering alone he wished to
create an evil dynasty to rule
underneath him and carry out his every
command across the multiverse he decided
that sana would be his first bride and
forebearer to the first generation of
his spawn she was made to lay with him
for seven days and seven nights so that
she could give birth to seven children
seven being a highly significant number
in the world of sorcery and particularly
in the world of kintigor once sana had
served this purpose kintigor who could
not feel anything even close to love had
no more use for her and crushed her to
death when he rose up from this grisly
deed his armor was covered in sana's
blood this striking image inspired his
final name shormage urdau the scarlet
king from santa the scarlet king gained
seven daughters who in an act of further
monstrosity he also made his seven
brides each gave birth to a legion of
nightmares which would become the
scarlet king's most loyal and dangerous
soldiers the scarlet king also gave each
of these brides a secret seal so that
they would never die the first bride was
atovic who was the favorite of the
scarlet king despite having the smallest
brood she and her children were granted
great wisdom that would guide them to
victory in battle her seal was vadok
dominion the second bride was agor born
with a great hole in her soul that left
her forever in want however she gave
birth to a huge legion who then begot
even greater armies to go forth and
conquer in the name of their terrible
grandfather her seal was kiffin longing
the third bride was aristat a creature
of unparalleled malice and hatred that
extended to even her own sisters she and
her brood were unmatched in their
ability to spread desolation destruction
and pestilence on the battlefield her
seal was hezhom desolation the fourth
bride was azieb the great berserker if
ever there was one she took the form of
a huge beast as did all her children
they would rampage through enemy forces
killing scores of soldiers yet seemingly
impervious to all damage dealt against
them her seal was ba
wrath the fifth bride was annat a beast
with a frail body but an incredible mind
her children all proved to be adept
sorcerers with the ability to craft and
rework reality however they pleased this
would prove to be a great asset to the
scarlet king but he also feared that
their powers would allow them to rebel
against him and so he had them all
crippled her seal was near
black the sixth bride was ateliff the
most silent and secretive of all the
scarlet siblings her children had the
remarkable ability to change their faces
and walk unnoticed amongst their enemies
they also had the ability to open the
ways between worlds allowing the scarlet
king's endless war to spread across
dimensions her seal was ushek hidden and
the seventh and final bride was ahebat
who was physically the weakest of them
all but the only one with the strength
of spirit to disagree with and rebel
against her father's diabolical wishes
her children were brave warriors and
hunters many of which are aligned with
her mission to stop the dreaded scarlet
king though thus far none have yet
achieved this lofty mission her seal was
oxkib hope as the scarlet king's power
grew more of the multiverse fell into
his poisonous clutches rotting the very
roots of the tree of life as the seven
brides and their legions spread out they
recruited more cosmic players for their
grand war effort the hanged king pledged
his allegiance the prince of many faces
swore his loyalty to the scarlet king
the demonic forces of the factory worked
in the name of the unholy monarch and
the horned demon lord moloch bowed his
mighty head the devites firmly believe
that the victory of their almighty
scarlet king was as certain as the
sunset no matter what opposes him be it
the serpent the broken god the arrogant
fools like the scp foundation he and his
forces will fight on they will tear the
tree of life asunder carving away at
everything until nothing remains
existence will be at its end and the
last sound the multiverse hears will be
the scarlet king himself sighing in
relief after a job well done he will
finally be at peace unless of course
somebody stops him if the best minds the
foundation has to offer with all of its
resources and knowledge and connections
are able to create some kind of weapon
or shield against him if scp-999 truly
is the child of ahabat prophesies to
bring about the end of the scarlet
king's terrible conquest if there is
some unknown solution waiting out there
in the dark we may finally be able to
stop this rampaging elder god from
destroying all we hold dear but those
are all very big ifs calvin lucian leads
the kill squad team through the mud and
freezing rain in front of them looms the
fortress of baron lehman hoadley the
eighth overseer the team has already
been through a lot from breaking the
overseer council's deal with death by
eliminating 05-13
to using the spearer of the non-believer
to kill the godlike archivist 05-10 the
hunting of overseers has taken a toll on
the kill squad oh 5-12 almost killed
adam and olivia was stuck in what seemed
like an endless mind game with 05-11
the first five overseers were eliminated
but the words that the ninth overseer
spoke to calvin lucian before she died
still run through his mind are you
afraid of death now the kill squad is
about to infiltrate one of the most
heavily guarded facilities in the world
to eliminate the eighth overseer upon
reaching the castle the team is
surprised to find the structure is in
ruin no one is supposed to know the
location of 05-8 though the fortress was
supposed to be practically impregnable
they stormed the castle of 05-8 all the
same the journal calvin possesses that
contains information about the members
of the scp foundation's powerful 05
council identifies him as a former
industrialist named baron lehmann
hoadley with his vast wealth hoadley
funded the foundation at the start and
was considered the unofficial leader of
the council in its early days with
immense control over the actions of the
organization the kill squad makes their
way through the dimly lit hallways of
the castle as they turn the corner they
are surprised to find the charred
remains of baron lehman hoadley's
bodyguards it seems that someone or
something has gotten too hodly before
they could the team makes their way to
the main chamber and breaches the door
laying by a still-lit fireplace is 05-8
the kill squad scans the room to make
sure the killer isn't still in there
with them adam walks over to the body
and examines it he quickly realizes that
hoadley hasn't been murdered at all he
sees that baron hoadley's body has been
drastically modified using anomalous
technology the overseer used his
immortality to modify almost every part
of his body to make himself stronger
unfortunately for baron hoadley when the
overseer's deal with death was broken by
calvin the modifications to his body
slowly tore him apart his regular body
could no longer support all the
modifications and what once made him
practically invincible became the very
thing that destroyed him the team leaves
the castle and crosses 05-8 off their
list on their way out adam pulls calvin
aside he has the feeling that anthony
hasn't been completely honest with the
rest of the team he had the feeling that
anthony was hiding something from them
calvin had similar thoughts recently he
pushes anthony for more information
about his past and anthony reveals that
he's over 100 years old the vial of
water from the fountain of youth that
calvin has was not the only one early in
his career with the insurgency he had
confiscated other vials from a
foundation site his squad drank the
water and it extended their lives he
asks calvin on what he plans on doing
with his water from the fountain i'm
going to destroy it calvin tells him
anthony agrees with his plan once you
drink from the fountain of youth you may
extend your life but a part of you dies
at the same time vibrancy of the senses
disappears leading to a seemingly
shallow life if anthony could go back
and do it again he never would have
drank the water calvin receives intel
from the insurgency that the seventh
overseer is in a small town in cambodia
the kill squad makes their way to the
village and surveys the area hoping to
get a glimpse at the overseer who's
codenamed green as the team conducts
reconnaissance anthony tells them that
he thinks the mission is a setup it is
too remote and there are so many unknown
variables but calvin is convinced that
this might be their only chance to kill
green since green arrived in the area
there has been non-stop chaos she has
destabilized the local governments and
now the area is in an all-out war the
team weaves through narrow passageways
between houses and buildings trying to
make their way to the central compound
where green is located suddenly a mob
starts to form they are getting closer
and closer to the team in a quick
decision to avoid being seen calvin
orders everyone into a nearby building
before anthony can follow the mob rounds
the corner they spot anthony and he's
forced to flee calvin olivia and adam
watch as the mob chases after anthony
but they have to keep moving calvin
knows that anthony can take care of
himself and they're too close to their
goal to stop now calvin slowly opens the
front door of the house they are hiding
in and peers out the coast looks clear
so he signals olivia and adam to follow
him before they can step out into the
street a gas canister enters through a
crack doorway the room fills with
sleeping gas and the team passes out
when they are awake they are tied up in
a large room with marble vaulted
ceilings 05-7 is standing in front of
calvin she smiles wickedly while holding
a knife she compliments calvin on what
he and his team have been able to do so
far no one believed they could pull off
even a fraction of what they have but
now she has an offer for calvin she
points towards adam and olivia and tells
calvin he must choose one of them to die
if he doesn't she'll kill the leader of
the rioters and plunge another part of
the country into chaos screw you is
calvin's response very well utter screen
have it your way she assassinates the
leader being held in her compound then
turns back to calvin she now threatens
to torture his team until calvin makes a
choice of who to kill green slashes
adam's cheek with her knife as calvin
screams for green to leave his team
alone and torture him instead green just
smiles i'm going to enjoy killing your
friends while you watch as you have
killed so many of my overseers on the
council she reaches up in the air with a
knife above adam's head before she can
plunge the knife through his skull a
bullet passes through her hand causing
her to drop the knife anthony kneels on
a rooftop across the courtyard smoking
sniper rifles still pointed at green who
runs calvin uses the dropped knife to
cut his ropes and chases after green he
follows her to the roof where he watches
as she boards a helicopter the aircraft
lifts off as anthony fires at it from
his original position but does no
serious damage in the plaza below the
mob that has separated the team earlier
becomes restless there is complete chaos
and someone fires a rocket at the
fleeing helicopter the rocket hits the
tail of the aircraft sending it crashing
into the plaza full of rioters below as
the crowd flees from the scene calvin
makes his way towards the wreckage and
reaches it at the same time anthony does
calvin looks at him smiles and thanks
him for saving his life anthony smiles
back but before he can say anything a
gunshot rings out and a bullet rips
through his neck calvin turns to see
where it came from and is horrified to
see the burning body of 05-7
her skin has been charred black but in
her burnt hand she holds a gun what's
left of her lips curl back in the
sinister grin as she fires again and
hits anthony in the chest he falls to
the ground kelvin runs to him and pulls
out his gun to shoot 05-7 but she is
already dead calvin holds his dying
teammate as blood pours out of his neck
and chest but calvin can stop this he
pulls out the vial of water from the
fountain
no when says anthony i have lived long
enough thank you my friend i will see
you in whatever lies beyond this life
anthony's chest rises then falls it does
not rise again olivia and adam round the
corner to see calvin holding the
lifeless body of their teammate tears
flowing from his eyes the team holds a
small ceremony and burial for anthony
but are only halfway through their
mission and can't stop now they fly back
to the united states where an undercover
insurgency agent named kowalski informs
them that 05-6 is already aware they're
after him this overseer is code named
the american because he has the power of
the entire u.s military at his
fingertips the kill squad scouts the
base where the american is located
kowalski warns them of a crate that was
recently brought to the base from site
19. the americans showed great interest
in whatever was in the container the
group sets up a camp on a hill
overlooking the base as the sun slowly
rises the next day the kill squad is
spotted by a drone and forced to hop in
their jeep and try to run they make
their way down the hill finding
themselves in the valley below with no
clear exit in front of them lands a
helicopter as humvees roar into the
canyon behind them the team is
surrounded a jeep pulls up and 05-6
steps out he introduces himself as rufus
king member of the overseer council but
an american citizen first and foremost
all he really wants is to protect the
country he loves thanks to you i've lost
my immortality and can no longer
effectively protect the united states
anymore the american says to kelvin but
i'm willing to make a deal your freedom
for the spear of the non-believer rumor
has it that you have the spear in your
possession and you used it to kill the
archivist you give me the spear i will
let you go no replies calvin i will
never give an overseer the means to
cause more destruction the spear stays
with us
very well the american says with a frown
then i suppose my only other option is
to take it from you but not without
giving you a fair chance
run calvin lucian run as fast as you can
i
will be coming
for you
the american turns and walks towards the
container from site 19 which is being
lowered from a helicopter hovering above
them calvin sprints back to the jeep
with the other members of his team as
they drive away they hear a horrible
guttural screech from whatever was
inside the container after a few moments
the army begins to pursue them out in
front of the military force is 05-6
writing
scp-688
he is using a black whip to urge the
creature forward and they're gaining on
the kill squad
fast a row of vehicles pulls up beside
the american and scp-682
then something strange happens a man
appears in front of the oncoming forces
led by the american the man's skin
bulges and seems to be moving from
within the skin of the man slouse from
his body the infection that is
scp-610 erupts out of him and onto the
soldiers in the nearby jeep
scp-610 begins to infect and consume
everyone around it suddenly there are
thousands of instances of scp-610 coming
from the mountainside flooding into the
valley they close in and around the army
and 05-6
the american begins fighting off the
flesh-eating creatures from the back of
scp-682
but he becomes overwhelmed he can no
longer focus on pursuing calvin and his
team
from the back of the jeep olivia pulls
out her rifle she aims and fires the
bullet hits the american in the chest he
is flung off the back of scp-682
and engulfed in a sea of scp-610
creatures
the kill squad continues to drive trying
to put as much distance between
themselves and the scp-610 infestation
as possible but then calvin suddenly
slams on the brake standing in front of
them is a man in a black suit and bow
tie he introduces himself as blackbird
the fifth overseer according to the
journal his actual name is mortimer j
denning von krucnicker he stands in
front of the jeep with a menacing grin
you have been causing a lot of trouble
he says looking at calvin olivia swings
her gun around oh please my dear that
won't help you von krocnecker says he
pulls out a knife and stabs himself
through the neck he falls to the ground
apparently dead there is a gust of wind
a whiff of ozone and an identical copy
and still very much alive on krucnecker
lands next to his own dead body see what
i mean he says olivia lowers her rifle
come with me i have something to show
you the blackbird beckons seeing no
other option calvin olivia and adam exit
the jeep and follow the blackbird as
they walk the world changes around them
the desert mountains fade away into
blackness and find themselves in the
near apocalyptic london oh it's good to
be home the blackbird says as they
emerge onto a cobblestone street you
cannot stop the overseer's plans however
i can give you an alternative let's see
if any of you will take it in front of
each kill squad member appears a door
they have an uncontrollable urge to open
their respective door and walk through
the blackbird stands smiling as he
watches calvin olivia and adam enter
each of their portals adam enters his
door and looks around he is in portland
his parents walk into the room in this
universe his family has been granted
asylum adam never has to interact with
any scps or the foundation he is free to
live a normal life from the kitchen
comes calvin wearing an apron he is
holding a steaming pot adam locks eyes
with calvin who smiles at him the
blackbird whispers into adam's ear in
this reality both of your parents and
siblings are still alive also the man
you love loves you back you and calvin
could be married if you stayed here
wouldn't that be nice olivia enters her
door she is on the deck of a yacht at
the bow sits an easel with art supplies
the man that olivia once loved walks
across the deck towards her the
blackbird looms over her in this reality
you didn't accidentally kill him this
could be your happily ever after
wouldn't that be nice calvin steps
through his door he is in a grassy
clearing near a lake the blackbird
hisses in calvin's ear i'm giving you
the opportunity to save your mother this
time calvin you were just a scared
little boy but in this reality you can
be brave you can actually save your
mother from her faith no calvin screams
this isn't real the blackbird cackles
calvin looks away from the lake and
towards the tree line hidden in the
shadows he can just barely make out a
hooded figure calvin walks towards it
the blackbird follows he is screaming at
the person in the tree line i was only
trying to help the hooded figure reaches
out and hands calvin a metal tube he
opens it to find a set of eyeglasses
inside calvin puts them on and turns to
look at the blackbird he steps back in
horror the glasses have revealed the
true form of the blackbird he is a
winged pseudo-avian monstrosity full of
rage the mysterious hooded figure
directs calvin to open the tube again
inside is an interdimensional fishing
line made by dr wondertainment and a
white wiffle ball bat calvin grabs the
fishing line and wraps it around
05-5's leg the blackbird flies into the
air trying to get away from calvin but
calvin wraps the other end of the
fishing line around his arm the
blackbird begins to jump from dimension
to dimension trying to get rid of calvin
they appear on the deck of
scp-455 in site 19 where scp-682 walks
freely in the dead world of scp-2935
every time they stop in a new dimension
calvin takes the opportunity to attack
the blackbird with the bad and it seems
that he is slowly weakening the monster
they finally land at the bottom of a
deep well foundation containment site
where the dark body that is scp-001
is contained standing in front of the
containment field is alison cho the
black queen whose sole mission is to
destroy the foundation you cries the
blackbird you are the one who's been
helping lucian the black queen nods her
head yes i have been helping calvin
lucian to eliminate you and the other
overseers the foundation must fall you
are nothing you cannot stop me i am the
black king
screams 05-5 alison chow sighs she
pushes a button on the panel next to her
shutting down the array containing the
dark body out of the cloud of dust
appears
scp-001 a massive black creature who
seemed to absorb all light no stop
shrieks the blackbird scp-001
does not move but the room begins to
shake the blackbird continues to scream
as his body folds in on itself until he
is reduced to a single superheated point
and then blinks out of existence alison
chao then reactivates the containment
array
ceiling001 away once again i will return
you to your reality along with your
friends says the black queen but perhaps
our path shall cross again calvin lucian
there is a bright flash of light and
calvin finds himself on a private jet
sitting next to olivia and adam they are
all shaken but the blackbird is dead
05-5 has been eliminated the three
members of the team sit silently still
pondering what might have been if they
stayed in the alternate realities
suddenly the phone on the plane begins
to ring breaking the silence calvin
picks it up on the other line is the
fourth overseer he has contacted calvin
to discuss surrendering to the
insurgency unfortunately things do not
always go as planned calvin lucian is
about to make the most difficult and
dangerous decision of his life it was
1948 in vila blanca guatemala as night
fell two young boys carlos and miguel
played a game of soccer in the street it
was a quiet town full of humble
hard-working people and they were about
to come face to face with a monster
typically when something like this
happened you'd know exactly who to call
the scp foundation problem is while
these days we can generally depend on
the hard-working agents and researchers
of the foundation to save us from any
anomalous supernatural threats with
their tactics expertise and equipment it
wasn't always this way there was a time
before the scp foundation became the
titan of anomaly combating prowess it is
today and it's that time that we're
focusing on today it all comes back to a
strange and violent creature wandering
the darkened streets of guatemala or as
dr charles ogden gears proposed we call
it
scp-001 the prototype
scp-001 is a topic that we've covered in
a number of videos but even then we can
never quite capture the full scope of
this wiley designation what is scp-001
is probably one of the most loaded
questions you can possibly ask a member
of the scp foundation and it may be your
last as the majority of the files under
the scp-001 umbrella are highly
classified for pretty much everyone
under level 5 clearance 001 covers a
large number of potentially anomalous
items entities and concepts from the
dreaded scarlet king to the
awe-inspiring gate guardian to the very
scp foundation itself through the eyes
of the charmingly incompetent unusual
incidence unit of the fbi perhaps
they're all real perhaps only one of
them is and the rest are in there as a
smoke screen perhaps they're all fake
red herrings laid down to hide the trail
to something even more secretive and
fantastic all we know is that 001 seemed
to be gathered around a collection of
loose themes the beginnings of the
foundation events or entities that could
end the foundation or even the world and
key formative moments in the
foundation's history dr gear's proposal
for scp-001 lies firmly in the latter
camp and if you keep watching and
listening closely you'll see exactly why
back to carlos and miguel the pair of 11
year olds playing football on the quiet
back streets of villa blanca they were
kicking the ball back and forth when
they heard a strange screeching noise in
the distance at first they thought it
was some kind of injured bird squawking
desperately for help being good kids
they didn't waste a second running into
the action heading further into the
outskirts of town however the creature
they encountered on that rural road was
certainly no bird when they first saw it
hunched over a few meters in front of
them they thought it must have been a
horribly injured man it was deadly thin
with gray brown skin that looked either
bruised or burned it was twitching and
weeping its chest heaving in heavy
labored pants its limbs were jerking
wildly as though the creature was being
electrocuted hey mister are you okay
carlos called out in spanish in that
moment what they had wrongly thought was
a man just froze up finally registering
their presence immediately the two boys
knew something was wrong as the creature
slowly rose to its full height well over
six feet towering over the two of them
even at a distance they noticed
something was wrong with its limbs they
were too long well out of proportion
with its human-sized torso it didn't
have hands and feet at least not in the
way that humans do instead its slender
ankles terminated in long black spikes
and its wrists each split off into three
equally black claws but worst of all was
its face if you could even call what
that monster had a face
its head was split in the middle by a
huge mouth at first its gnarly lips were
pursed but they soon slid open with a
low rumbling roar the boys could feel
their knees shaking as they saw the
monster's mouth full of long rotten
fangs something started sliding up the
dark passage of the monster's throat a
translucent milky blue sphere was that
thing an eye it made the two boys feel
sick to even look at it that's when the
eye started to glow and the space around
the monster began to shimmer slightly
like some kind of terrible sorcery as
the two boys felt a strange force
pulling at them trying to tug them into
the creature's embrace they were
suddenly jogged from their frightened
paralysis and decided to finally make a
run for it there was no doubt about what
had just happened they'd encountered a
demon in the flesh intent on taking
their souls straight to hell when the
two of them told their parents they were
met at first with disbelief two young
boys saw something that frightened them
in the dark perhaps an animal if
anything at all and they'd let their
imaginations run wild it was typical of
children however things didn't seem
quite so simple when more sightings
started popping up people all across the
town of vila blanca started seeing this
monster all with matching descriptions a
huge emaciated beast with a mouth for a
face its glowing blue eye nested inside
the natural excuses circulated at first
perhaps the creature was a local
prankster in a costume this would be
comforting to believe but how many
pranksters and costumes can completely
disappear before your very eyes the
monster's eye would glow and just like
that it would simply vanish as fear and
paranoia began spreading through the
town people suggested that perhaps it
was a case of mass hysteria fear and
panic taking over rationality but by
this point things had gotten worse
carlos and miguel the two boys who'd
first discovered the demon on the back
road had become sick they were
experiencing severe nausea vomiting
headaches and diarrhea their bodies
weakened lesions began developing on
their skin as their conditions
deteriorated and it seemed as though
nobody was capable of treating them a
rumor spread that the monster was
somehow inducing this sickness the town
doctor didn't have the expertise to
diagnose it but the boys were suffering
from acute radiation sickness and they
wouldn't be the only ones many of the
people who'd reported sightings and
close encounters with the monster
started coming down with severe
radiation sickness to the townspeople it
just seemed to be a demon spreading some
invisible plague among them but the
horrors wouldn't stop there it seemed
that this demon also liked to take a
more direct approach to harming the
townsfolk because not long after the
sickness broke out people started
disappearing there were never any bodies
the most that would ever be found were
tattered items of clothing left at the
site of the disappearances or blood
smeared across the walls or ground
before they knew it seven of their
people were gone it seemed that for all
intents and purposes god had abandoned
them they were playthings of the demon
now thankfully for the townsfolk who
weren't yet irradiated or vanished an
organization was forming one that might
be their only chance at salvation
someday in the future it would become
known as the scp foundation but it had a
lot to learn before it got there you see
the reason that this iteration of
scp-001 is known as the prototype is
that if dr gears is to be believed it
may be the first anomalous entity that
they ever truly faced so naturally
getting the creature captured and
contained didn't go quite as smoothly as
most of their modern jobs despite the
comparative simplicity of this old
threat general machoy an ex-military
operator that became part of what we'll
once again call the precursors to the
foundation led a research and recovery
team into villa blanca to hunt down and
retrieve the beast that had been causing
all this misery and death among the
townsfolk however this proved to be
easier said than done while its beastial
appearance might fool people into
thinking the monster was just a mindless
animal later writings on the creature
would describe it as both incredibly
cunning and terrifyingly fast when a
group of armed personnel first tried to
engage the creature directly they had no
idea that they were walking right into
the middle of a bloodbath they believed
they had it surrounded on another rural
back road advancing with assault rifles
when the creature flipped out and
started killing them the prototype
proved to have frightening offensive
capabilities its three dark claws easily
carved through the armor of the soldiers
trying desperately to contain it the
creature moved so fast that none of them
could reliably draw a bead on it and if
any of them could it was holding their
severed head before they had a chance to
squeeze the trigger but death by the
creature's claws was one of the more
pleasant ways it could kill its victims
at one point during an engagement with
precursor troops it opened its mouth and
unveiled its glowing blue eye at this
point one of the soldiers screamed and
suddenly seemed to be sucked inside of
himself completely disappearing the
prototype's blue eye glowed again and it
once again just teleported away from the
scene a number of soldiers who survived
this altercation later needed to be
treated for acute radiation sickness
researchers eventually managed to figure
out what was actually happening with the
creature it had the ability to manifest
micro singularities tiny black holes
that he used to both teleport from place
to place and defend itself from attacks
when necessary these singularities
wouldn't stick around for long a few
seconds at most but they had the
terrifying side effect of putting out
massive amounts of radiation this is why
it was making so much of the town and
the recovery team sick via mere
proximity thankfully in finding out the
creature's strength they also managed to
find out its weaknesses its powers were
dampened by high humidity bright lights
and especially intense strobing lights
it was through the use of these lights
that the creature was finally captured
and brought into adrx-19
a complex that would later become site
19 for containment there its containment
procedures were devised by one of the
burgeoning organization's top minds
dr hermann ketter however dr ketter
would sadly never actually live to see
the duration of the prototypes
containment at adr x-19 he was
tragically killed by the monster though
his name would live on as the
designation for anomalies that were
particularly difficult to contain it was
thanks to him that his co-workers
realized lead line walls a reinforced
steel door a 100 humidity environment
and the frequent application of high
intensity strobe lights were the best
way to keep the prototype locked up for
good to this day this iteration of
scp-001
is a fascinating reminder that the scp
foundation wasn't always the juggernaut
it is today there was once a time where
they had as little idea of what they
were doing as the rest of us there's no
better representation of this than the
file itself it was an error before
object classes and conventional
designation numbers the file is written
in a sketchy disorganized manner and
arranged into item designation number
warning description of item detail of
current containment report and addendum
as with any experience in life it's
always worth asking what can we learn
from the scp foundation's experience
with its possible first anomaly a
monster that seems almost nostalgically
quaint by today's standards perhaps the
greatest message is that everything is a
work in progress it was only by
determination and persistence that the
foundation could go from an organization
challenged by a monster like the
prototype to going toe to toe with real
heavy hitters like the scarlet king how
very inspirational aaron siegel better
known to foundation members as 05-1
descends into the abyss of a deepwall
site he exits the elevator and peers
into the optical scanner to unlock the
reinforced door inside the room is
mobile task force tau5 samsara aaron
siegel refers to these immortal cyborg
clones created from the flesh of a dead
god as his red right hand your mission
is to eliminate the traitor 05-4 and to
find the insurgents who have been
killing the members of the overseer
council the cyborg stand at attention
now aaron siegel screams the soldiers of
the red right hand march out the door to
start their mission aaron siegel pauses
for a moment and then slams his fist
against the wall in frustration he has
lost nine overseers to calvin lucian and
his kill squad team they have been
somehow overcoming the odds each time
and eliminating each overseer they
tracked down it wasn't supposed to end
this way aaron siegel vows to kill them
all calvin lucian meanwhile sits on a
private jet with adam and olivia he had
just hung up the phone after a
conversation with o5-4 the overseer
known as the ambassador wants to
surrender to the insurgency there's a
good chance this is a trap but calvin
has decided to meet with the ambassador
all the same calvin drops off adam and
olivia at an insurgency base they still
haven't fully recovered from the
previous mission with 05-5 known as the
blackbird before leaving though calvin
meets with an insurgency agent named
sylvester sloan who is going to join him
as support calvin says goodbye to adam
and olivia then leaves with sloan to
meet the ambassador in south africa
after landing at johannesburg airport
calvin and sloane disembark and are led
to a conference room where the
ambassador sits waiting for them calvin
and sloane sit across from mo 5-4 to
discuss his surrender the council is in
shambles says the ambassador everything
is falling apart i want to offer my
services and information to the
insurgency in exchange for protection
from o5-1 he has lost his mind galvan
agrees to the terms and prepares for
extraction but as they get up from the
table gunshots can be heard from down
the hall the ambassador's eyes open wide
in terror it's too late he whispers
calvin and sloane grab the ambassador
who is frozen in fear and exit the
conference room they make their way
towards their plane but the gunshots are
getting closer calvin looks over his
shoulder to see samsara pursuing them
through the terminal calvin shoves the
ambassador behind a table as bullets
whiz overhead calvin and sloane return
fire but their volley doesn't seem to
slow down the assassins calvin and sloan
pull the ambassador to his feet and they
burst through an emergency exit onto the
sun-baked tarmac where they make a mad
dash for the plane from behind them a
bullet rips through the chest of sloan
the red right hand has caught up but
calvin continues to drag the ambassador
towards the plane they are almost there
suddenly a metallic child's voice blares
through the airport's external speakers
the child's voice says i want calvin
lucian alive i have business to settle
with him the red right-hand soldiers
tackle calvin and the ambassador to the
ground when they are just feet away from
the plane kill the traitor the child's
voice says and calvin can only watch
helplessly as the ambassador is
violently murdered one of the agents
turns towards calvin and slams his fist
into calvin's face causing him to
blackout calvin awakes in a dark room
he is unsure how much time has passed
the only light in the room comes from a
screen on the wall in the middle of the
screen is a rotating red scp foundation
seal a voice from a speaker speaks hello
calvin lucian my name is the kid i am
the third overseer you have killed all
my friends and now i will kill all of
yours the door to the room opens calvin
leans through the doorway there is a
long dimly lit hallway the kid orders
him to proceed so they can meet face to
face as calvin walks the kid's voice
echoes down the hallway there once was
another 05-3 he built incredible
machines even one that could see into
the future but unfortunately for him he
did not have the passion required to be
an overseer that was when i was
born i was chosen by the other overseers
to have my spinal cord severed in a way
that gave me the ability of the
all-seeing eye i now watch everything
all of the time i have perfect reasoning
perfect awareness and perfect
understanding calvin gets to the end of
the corridor which opens up into a large
chamber tied up in the middle of the
room are olivia and adam calvin runs to
his friends and crouches down next to
them a mechanical suit stands on a
platform looking down at calvin olivia
and adam calvin realizes the kid must be
contained inside
i now sentence you all to death the
mechanical suit says as the red right
hand steps out of the shadows and slowly
walks towards the remaining members of
the kill squad suddenly there is a flash
of light and the black queen appears
stop what are you doing shriek's the kid
the black queen hands calvin the
interdimensional rod and reel he used to
defeat the blackbird calvin casts the
rod from out of the terror in space
comes a massive multi-armed creature
known as maladramigion the red right
hand engages the monster trying to force
it back into its dimension but the
monster is too powerful he grabs the
cyborg clones and pulls them through the
tear in reality as samsara battles the
melodramagion calvin frees olivia and
adam they make a run for the door but as
they flee one of the walls opens up to
reveal a turin the gun fires and a
bullet hits olivia directly in the head
killing her instantly no yells calvin
before calvin can push adam out of the
way a second bullet from the turret
lodges itself and adam's back calvin and
adam slide across the floor the kid in
his mechanical suit jumps down from the
platform above i'm going to kill you now
calvin lucian he says in his mechanical
voice there is another flash of light
calvin watches in front of him as the
spear of the non-believer manifests
itself before his eyes kelvin grabs the
spear and shoves it into the kid's
machine body it easily penetrates the
armor and pins him to the wall calvin
walks up to the exoskeleton and tears
off the outer plating revealing a tank
full of fluid within which floats a
malformed human fetus as calvin finally
looks upon the kid's true form he hears
the sound of mocking mechanical laughter
calvin breaks the glass and crushes the
kid with his bare hands as calvin turns
from the now silent robotic body of the
kid the room begins to shake debris is
raining down from above calvin helps
adam up and puts olivia's lifeless body
across his shoulders what remains of the
kill squad makes their way out of the
kid's lair outside of the foundation
side where they were being held calvin
helps adam lie down on the ground before
gently setting olivia's body next to him
adam grimaces as blood pours out of the
wound in his back calvin reaches into
his pocket and pulls out the vial of
water from the fountain of youth there
are only a couple of drops left which he
pours into adam's mouth adam looks up at
calvin tears filling his eyes he
whispers i love you before he passes out
from the pain the wound in his back
begins to heal instantly and calvin
calls an insurgency evac team to come
pick up adam with adam safe calvin picks
up olivia and walks alone towards a
truck in the lot outside of the
foundation site he needs to finish this
once and for all he will kill the last
two overseers or he will die trying 05-1
aaron siegel arrives at where the tigris
and euphrates rivers meet the garden of
eden he is in a frenzy due to the
assassinations of all the other
overseers besides himself and the
nazarene and nothing will stop him as he
approaches the gate to the garden of
eden though he is stopped by the
guardian of the garden a massive
powerful anomalous entity with a flaming
sword but aaron siegel has no time or
patience for anything to get in his way
even something as powerful as the gate
guardian the guardian swings his burning
sword at adam who rolls out of the way
and in a flash takes out a scranton
reality anchor he slams the anchor into
the ground which causes the world to
shimmer and riffle around him he watches
as the flames from the gate guardian
sword seem to absorb back into its body
before it shrinks down looking to fold
in on itself until all that is left is a
charred skeleton with the guardian
defeated aaron sprints into the garden
he searches the garden 405-2 but can't
find her anywhere he finally comes to
the tree of life and that's where he
finds her laying at the base of the tree
in a pool of blood is the nazarene she
has taken her own life this is her
anomalous power though she has died many
times before yet death always spared her
and brought her back but somehow he
knows this time is final aaron drops to
his knees and screams in frustration for
all the power aaron siegel possesses
there's nothing he can do now he sits
next to the nazarene's body for hours
hoping that she might wake up or that he
will to find that this was all a dream
after sitting next to her cold body for
some time he notices something in her
snowy white hand it's a no in it the
nazarene explains that she was the one
who gave the vials from the fountain to
calvin lucian and that she is the one
who made the spear appear before him
that he used to kill the kid she
explained that while she died many times
and death always brought her back each
time she felt less and less like herself
less and less like dr sophia light she
hoped that maybe if things ended up like
this it would give aaron the chance to
walk away and live the life that they
might have been able to have together
but she knows deep down that aaron's
fade is to meet calvin and finish things
once and for all aaron siegel screams
and rage clutching the node in his hand
he tries to summon death but no one
becomes aaron siegel is alone he stands
up and walks deeper into the garden he
walks until he reaches a spot where even
god's light does not reach in this
desolate land is an impact crater where
lucifer star of the morning had fallen
in the middle of the crater lies
lucifer's sword aaron siegel descends
into the hole and picks up the sword he
turns and exits the garden of eden aaron
siegel has only one mission in life now
to kill calvin lucian calvin reads the
final entry of the journal in it the
author warns that although he hopes the
information contained within the journal
is helpful he hopes the reader does not
try to use it the words written on the
final page are this information will
only lead you to a devastating end
calvin closes the journal and looks up
at the structure in front of him he has
made it to scite01 he had left olivia's
body in a cave nearby promising to her
that he would make this right he now
walks up to the massive doors and places
his hand on the knotted wood the doors
slowly creak open calvin pauses for a
moment and looks behind him at the
setting sun he enters site site-01 where
he knows 05-1 is where aaron siegel
waits inside the main hall calvin sees a
giant doorway in the shape of the scp
foundation seal with artistic depictions
of certain scps that he instinctively
knows are special in some way standing
next to the doorway is a two meter tall
man in what looks to be a futuristic
suit calvin approaches and asks who this
giant man is he responds that his name
is purpose the red right hand he is the
guardian of o5-1 and none shall enter
the sanctum until he returns he isn't
here ask calvin no purpose responds he
is and with that he steps aside and lets
calvin pass through the doorway the
doorway leads into a large room where
screens on the wall flash to life
depicting moments from calvin's journey
documenting his entire quest had he been
in control at all or was this all a
setup to lead him to this moment as he
walks forward he finally sees him
sitting at a table in the middle of the
room is aaron siegel euro 5-1 calvin
asks aaron the man responds my name is
aaron gavin asks about the location of
the second overseer the nazarene but
05-1 doesn't respond without needing any
more information calvin pulls out his
sidearm and in a flash fires off five
shots the bullets stopped in the air
inches from aaron before dissolving in a
flash of light calvin should have known
it wouldn't be this easy stand up aaron
siegel calvin calls up as he hosters his
gun let's finish it calvin pulled the
spear of the non-believer from his back
but aaron's only response was to laugh
you don't even know why you're here
aaron said calvin calls back i'm here to
kill you because when i do i kill the
foundation because when you're gone the
universe can finally heal you're like me
calvin lucian we are both men driven by
our own convictions regardless of the
outcome it would seem fate has brought
us together now either your convictions
will be broken or you will die
says aaron siegel he then draws
lucifer's flaming sword and lunges
towards calvin lucian as the two men
clash with one another their
supernatural weapons begin to destroy
the room around them furniture is
shattered video screens are obliterated
and fire spreads across the walls aaron
catches calvin off balance and swings
the flaming sword across calvin's
stomach calvin slides back from the
impact hunching over from the pain in
his midsection he brings his head up to
see aaron siegel running towards him
with the flaming sword high in the air
calvin brings up the spear from his
knees he leans back and launches it
towards aaron siegel the spear enters
the final overseer's chest the force
from the throw pinning him against the
wall aaron siegel drops lucifer's sword
it shatters as it hits the ground he
clutches the shaft of the spear
protruding from his sternum with both
hands oh 5-1 looks at calvin
unbelievingly
you have no idea what you've done
it was never about the overseers aaron
siegel says spitting out blood with
every word it was something deeper
something worse calvin walks slowly
towards aaron's seagull he stops just in
front of his final enemy this is the way
it ends calvin says aaron siegel manages
to whisper one final word sofia before
his body finally goes lim calvin turns
to see purpose standing behind him he's
dead calvin says half to purpose in half
to himself i killed him after a moment
he asks purpose what he really wants to
know there's a room in this facility
where someone could unmake the
foundation right take me there without
any hesitation purpose leads calvin back
to the room with depictions of important
scps there purpose opens the door to an
elevator but stops calvin before he can
get inside i am duty bound to tell you
purpose says that once you step inside
this elevator there is no going back
there is only one decision to be made
and it is not one that can be unmade i
know calvin responds it's time before
stepping inside the elevator opens a
door to reveal a room filled with
bookcases and a huge window offering a
beautiful view of the sun setting behind
the mountains on the wall are monitors
depicting the ways he had killed all of
the overseers and in the middle of the
room is a large desk with a computer
calvin sits down at the desk and the
computer comes to life the computer
prompts him to scan his fingerprint
which it accepts he's logged in the
computer screen displays numerous
locations around the planet and he
quickly recognizes that they are all scp
foundation science then he sees the
single option the computer is giving him
terminate calvin reaches out with his
finger this is it once he presses this
button the scp foundation will be no
more his finger is millimeters from the
button when the phone rings calvin
hadn't even noticed that there was a
phone on the desk calvin stares at it
for a moment then picks it up hello he
says the voice on the other line
responds hello calvin lucian my name is
the administrator i've been following
your work for some time now and i must
say i am impressed i have just been
informed that you have completed your
mission congratulations are in order
what the hell are you talking about
calvin asks please listen says the voice
on the other line the man you just
killed was once in the same exact
position you are in now granted it was a
very long time ago but aaron siegel
originally was trying to destroy the
foundation that was until i convinced
him otherwise and now like aaron siegel
you will become the new head of the
foundation like hell i will yells calvin
i could hang up and walk away right now
and be done with all this you could
continues the administrator but if no
one is in charge of the scp foundation
millions of people will die if not
billions and then nobody would be there
to manage what comes after there is
silence from calvin that's what i
thought says the administrator i look
forward to working with you calvin
lucian or should i say
05-1
the line goes dead
everyone worries about the future now
and then even members of the o5 council
the most powerful figures in the scp
foundation civilians resort to keeping
themselves in blissful ignorance or
relying on the calming platitudes of
horoscopes and fortune cookies but the
o5 council has access to considerably
more accurate methods of understanding
the future that's why when 05-2 began to
feel anxious about the future of the
human race she took matters into her own
hands she'd already spent time using
scp-2003
a device created by the foundation to
travel briefly into the future in hopes
of seeing what fate had in store for
humanity but very few of the futures
shown by scp-2003
were good ones for the human race with
many showing various end-of-the-world
scenarios playing out so instead 05-2
decided to make her way into existential
isolation facility beta an experimental
facility that contains an entirely
separate reality in order to get into
contact with scp-411
scp-411 is a centuries-old man from the
future who ages in reverse though his
advanced age has rendered him somewhat
senile useful facts about the future can
sometimes be noted from his scattered
memories of what is yet to come while
getting him to part with this
information is a risky procedure given
that 411 is so old that even extended
conversations might kill him in times of
absolute emergency it's sometimes the
clearest look into the future the
foundation has oh 5-2 hoped that in
talking to scp-411 she could settle some
of her anxieties regarding humanity's
future but the answers she got from the
senile bed-bound ancient precognitive
weren't exactly what she was hoping for
when she asked him whether there was a
future for humanity on earth he
responded the planet of hand is what we
are to speak of i am from there you know
as are you child you shall know more of
it in thai
i am glad to be here now instead
greetings prodigal daughter unlike me
you'll be home soon unsatisfied 05-2
left shortly after her anxiety
undeterred little did she know she had
very good reasons to be anxious about
humanity's future and we're not just
talking about nuclear war or climate
change we're talking about the threat
nobody expects scp-001
and this time it isn't the black moon or
the scarlet king or the terrifying when
day breaks today we're talking about
well we'll get to that in due time it'd
be a terrible shame to spoil the
surprise and besides there's a lot of
chaos and horror to get through before
then the foundation has always been
vaguely aware of scp-000
and the terrible threat it poses towards
all of humanity but that doesn't
necessarily mean they understand its
true nature still does it matter whether
or not a deer understands the hunter's
rifle no only that it must avoid being
found between its crosshairs and the
foundation's method for staying out of
zero zero one's crosshairs was known as
scp-2798 this thaumial class anomaly was
created by the foundation to
specifically keep 001 away from all of
us since the start of recorded history
strange anomalous activity has been
reported causing suffering and distress
against humans this eventually led to
the creation of the scp foundation which
seemingly correlated with a massive
spike in severe and dangerous anomalous
activity all of this activity was
believed to lead back to
scp-001 an anomalous hostile and highly
intelligent entity or series of entities
that wish to do humanity great harm
rather than playing whack-a-mole with
001's anomalies they hoped to deal with
its threat more directly leading to the
creation of
scp-2798 to go into too much detail
would probably derail the video entirely
but for us to give you a brief summary
of what exactly scp-2798
is it's comprised of 8 000 melted human
souls as well as several scps being
pumped down into the earth's mantle
while this came with certain unpleasant
side effects it also acted as a kind of
cloaking device by pumping so much life
essence into the earth it made us all
seem like one single organism thus
keeping the watchful eyes of scp-001
away from all of us this initiative was
given the code name project serapis
here's the problem though project
therapist was never meant to be a
permanent fix and what's more it's
actually been degrading over the last
several decades until it finally
recently collapsed earth's cloaking
device had collapsed with it and now the
eyes of scp-001 were starting to come
into focus on our pale blue dot and just
like o5-2 had feared things were about
to get an awful lot worse on november
2nd 2016
001 detected the population of earth and
began to work its terrifying magic it
began creating what is known as altered
phenomenon out of pre-existing anomalies
think of them almost as super scps
almost universally stronger and more
dangerous than their original
incarnations if you thought the scps
were dangerous before then these new
ones are your worst nightmare it didn't
take long for chaos to break out a huge
number of the foundation databases
across the globe experienced sudden
collapses the horrifying monster that
scp-058 the heart of darkness belonged
to began attacking its containment area
massive containment breaches occurred in
a huge number of sites and soldiers and
containment experts were dispatched in
hopes of bringing this rapidly
escalating situation back under control
photos of scp-439 the bone hive earwigs
were somehow leaked on imgur some
constellations even began disappearing
all over the sky
scp-1000s launched a violent coup and
took over blah luck oregon the global
zero zero one situations escalated and
anomalies began overwhelming different
foundation strongholds some sites were
considered lost though employees were
threatened with termination if they
abandoned their posts some anomalies
went entirely missing into the civilian
world and started causing chaos amal
hamzi one of the foundation's interfaith
liaisons from armed area 19 was quoted
saying the day will come when this earth
will be substituted with a new earth and
also the heavens and everyone will be
brought before god the one the supreme
allah preserve us you're probably
wondering given that an army of enhanced
scps were released to cause violence and
chaos across the globe by scp-001
do we have any specific examples of some
of the anomalies made bigger badder and
a hell of a lot more dangerous by this
mysterious foe don't worry the rest of
this video is going to be specific
examples of exactly that take for
example
scp-087 the endless stairwell this went
from a localized entity at an
undisclosed university administrative
building to an even more dangerous
stairwell in the pentagon which had the
ability to open and close its doorway at
will presumably hoping to capture some
power players from the united states
department of defense the terrifying
scp-106 also known as the old man also
got a significant power boost he became
so intelligent that he was capable of
conversing with foundation's staff
presumably just to say nasty things to
them as they tortured them to death he
was also able to better control his
dimensional portal abilities making
escape far easier which is bad news for
the human race given the old man's dark
tendencies
scp-294 the coffee machine got an
incredibly weird upgrade now rather than
dispensing items that can mess with
individuals it messes with a global
economy via the success or failure of
the coca-cola company one of the largest
beverage companies in the world
transactions performed on scp-294 will
affect the global stock price and
trading success for the company creating
wild economic instability
scp-662 the butler's handbell that
summons the delightfully practical
butler mr deeds went from convenient to
terrifying anytime it was wrong the
ringer was brought to a random unknown
location where they would be asked to
perform a seemingly impossible task and
then be anomalously compelled to
complete said task this could lead to
debilitating and distressing injuries
now you know how poor mr deeds feels
scp-701 the hanged king's tragedy was
originally a lethal cursed play that
causes madness and death for anyone
unlucky enough to witness it after
scp-001 the hanged king's tragedy was
transformed into a mass-marketed hbo
series starring javier bardem in the
title role the show was immediately
renewed for five seasons meaning it will
likely cause horrifying death and
madness for millions across the globe
although given hbo's track record the
last season is likely going to be
terrible
scp-993 was a disturbing anomalous
children's program hosted by the
infamous bobble the clown who would
convince the children in the audience to
commit violent or depraved acts thanks
to the scp-001 boost bobble instead took
up an adult news show on cable
television where he instead exerted his
violent influence over global power
players his guests have included then
united kingdom foreign secretary boris
johnson philippine president rodrigo
duerte canadian prime minister justin
trudeau and national people's congress
of china chairman zhang do zhang
scp-1981 also known as ronald reagan cut
up while talking was a cursed vhs tape
of a ronald reagan speech that shows the
former president being mutilated and
speaking violent nonsense naturally
thanks to scp-001 this obscure little
tape got a serious upgrade it became a
series of massively viewed videos on the
video sharing platform dailymotion it
shows a completely skinned version of
ronald reagan addressing the 2013
meeting of the world economic forum in
davos switzerland rather than the
typical blood and brimstone though the
content of each speech consists of
technical specifications for as yet
unknown anomalous technological devices
scp-2006 also known as too spooky was a
shape-shifter with the stated intention
of causing fear and horror in its
subjects but it thankfully wasn't very
good at this as the foundation tricked
it into occupying the forms of stupid
b-movie monsters however after the
scp-001 upgrade it shifted its goals to
causing happiness and contentment in
order to do this it took the form of
scp-999
but without any of its anomalous effects
instead it absorbed 15 agents saying
this is the closest anyone will be to
achieving happiness as they suffocated
within its inescapable gelatinous mass
scp-2337 also known as dr spanko was a
sentient and sapien male corn cake who
speaks bizarre nonsensical sentences at
an incredibly loud volume destroying
things with the sheer sound of its voice
however thanks to the extra power imbued
by scp-001
dr spenco entered the dream realm he
appeared to people in their dreams all
over the world causing considerable
distress to his victims by speaking to
them in his trademark deafening voice
this has caused general anxiety and
sleep deprivation to rise across the
human population
scp-2845 also known as the deer was
terrifyingly powerful before scp-001
ever got its hands on it this monster
had almost unparalleled reality warping
powers and was only kept contained in
site 100 by tricking it into believing
that the extensive rituals used to keep
it contained were actually effective
it's hard to say what specific form the
zero zero one upgrade took on scp-2845
but we do know that shortly after it
happened site 100 was lost entirely and
it became impossible to contact any
personnel who were previously within and
this is just a handful of the countless
anomalies that were turned into
dangerous and terrifying super scps by
scp-001
leading what seemed like a coordinated
attack not just against the foundation
but humanity itself all foundation
resources were directed towards getting
this new scp-001 situation back under
control and that started to stretch the
already dwindling resources of the
besieged foundation even thinner why was
this happening who or what was the
mysterious scp-001
and what did it hope to achieve by
making earth's anomalies stronger to
answer these questions and have any hope
of stopping this process before it tore
the world asunder the scp foundation
would need to go to deeper and darker
places than they'd ever gone before and
reckon with the secrets of their past
present and future we'd love to tell you
that this is where the horrors end but
stay tuned because sadly this little
nightmare is only the beginning calvin
lucian stands at the end of a dusty
table in an abandoned warehouse in the
shadows across from him sits several
hidden figures the warehouse is falling
apart but is suitable for the meeting
calvin has requested with the heads of
the chaos insurgency he has completed
numerous missions for the organization
and each one has been successful now he
is proposing one final mission calvin
lucian takes a tattered journal out of
his bag and slides it across the table
to the figure sitting in the shadows
it's a journal with details on the
habits of each of the 13 foundation
overseers he says there is silence from
the other end of the table a hand
reaches out and grabs the journal the
pages begin to turn the new models
indicate an anomalous catastrophe is
imminent not even the foundation can
stop it the only way to save the world
is to kill the overseers there are
whispers from across the table as calvin
continues the proliferation of anomalies
in the world are the fault of the
overseers they have been meddling with
reality the business continues as usual
we might not make it out of the 2020s we
need to act now the whispering from the
shadows resumes this time with what
seems to be a little more urgency one of
the voices asked the question on
everyone's mind how do you plan to kill
the overseers they have a deal with
death they are immortal calvin smiles
and takes out a small vial from his
jacket pocket with this he says there is
a silence from the shadows the journal
slides back across the table and comes
to a stop right in front of calvin a
deep voice from the shadows says
do it calvin lucian gathers his team the
code name given to the group is kill
squad he informs them that they've been
cleared to take out the overseers it
will be the most dangerous mission
they've ever been on and even if
successful they probably won't make it
out alive but the team is loyal they set
out to confront the 13th overseer this
has to be their first stop because
without eliminating 05-13
nothing else will matter it is this
overseer who has a deal with death a
deal that protects all of the foundation
overseers from dying if that deal can be
broken then calvin lucian and his team
will have a shot at eradicating the
other overseers if the deal with death
cannot be broken all is lost the team
boards a ship at the tip of south
america and sails towards the frozen
waters of antarctica the kill squad is
made up of calvin and three others they
sit in the galley preparing for the
mission ahead anthony wright is a
battle-hardened soldier who sits at one
end of the table his face is covered
with scars no one can remember when he
first joined the insurgency because it
was so long ago next to him is olivia
torres she is an anarchist who was
recruited into the insurgency after she
was liberated from a foundation site
during a raid adam ivanov sits staring
into his computer screen he is testing
different gadgets that might be of use
on the mission he pushes his glasses up
the bridge of his nose and strikes the
enter key a long line of code begins to
scroll across the screen a siren begins
to sound informing the crew to make
their way to the main deck when they
surface from the bowels of the ship they
see something in the distance it is a
giant black tower rising from the depths
of the ocean like an evil iceberg waves
crash over the side of the railings
drenching the deck and crew with frigid
water calvin looks at the jagged rocks
along the shore of the tower there is no
way to safely dock there is only one way
on to the island they know what needs to
be done anthony waits for the next wave
then opens the throttle to full the ship
is carried towards the island on the
crest of the wave the hull is impaled on
the rocks surrounding the tower sending
everything flying towards the front of
the boat see that wasn't so bad calvin
says to his team as he bandages a gash
on his hand knowing what lays ahead
calvin orders his team to wait on the
ship while he makes his own deal with
death he enters the dark structure and
is greeted by a corpse the corpse speaks
to him ejecting dust from its lungs with
every word its breath smells like
decaying flesh death has inhabited the
body of dr felix carter the 13th
overseer calvin is prepared though
thanks to the notes in the journal he
possesses without hesitating he takes
out a small bottle of liquid from his
pocket and lunges at the corpse he grabs
it by the neck tilts the head back and
pours liquid down what is left of the
throat to felix carter the corpse
reanimates into the living dr carter
death has been removed from his body by
liquid from the fountain of youth that
calvin had acquired on a previous raid
on a foundation site seeing that dr
carter is now alive calvin takes out his
pistol and shoots the doctor twice
killing him calvin picks up the body and
throws it into a bottomless pit at the
base of the tower dr felix carter's body
disappears from sight the overseer's
deal with death is now broken they are
vulnerable and can be killed at last
calvin smiles and begins to turn away
from the pit when he comes face to face
with death she stands with her head
cocked to the side looking at calvin so
it is you who has broken the overseer's
deal with me calvin lucian calvin takes
a step back why didn't she stop him from
killing felix carter something festers
at the heart of the council death says
something that will not die i thought
that perhaps if i had a seat at their
table i could find it make it die but i
couldn't there are things in this world
beyond even my reach calvin lucian with
that parting thought death vanishes the
kill squad contacts the insurgency for
an evac and then makes their way to
japan where 05-12 also known as the
accountant has been working out of tokyo
he is so proficient in mathematics and
probability that he can actually predict
the future everything about the
accountant's life down to the number of
breaths and steps he takes each day is
predetermined based on his own
statistical models this poses a problem
for calvin and his team if the
accountant can see them coming then how
can they possibly kill him that night
the accountant steps out of his car he
looks to the left and spots adam he has
already predicted this man has hostile
intentions the accountant walks directly
towards adam and before he can react
throws the kill squad member to the
ground then he turns slightly and
adjusts his watch sending a glare
directly into the window where anthony
has the accountant in his sights of his
sniper rifle anthony fires but misses
due to being blinded by the glare the
accountant is surprised that he just
barely had time to avoid being shot
normally he would be several steps ahead
of anyone trying to kill him he turns
his head and watches as olivia helps
adam up and they run down a nearby alley
the accountant pursues them and corners
the kill squad members in the alley he
pulls a gun to shoot adam but olivia
tackles adam behind a dumpster as the
bullet hits the wall directly behind
where adam was standing the accountant
can't believe that he missed and that he
was almost tricked into being captured
by the insurgency team he senses
uncertainty in his assailant's actions
and runs away unable to predict exactly
what they are planning to do the
accountant climbs the stairs to a subway
station and boards the last car of the
train it is empty except for one man
calvin lucian the accountant is
dumbfounded how are you here he screams
i should have seen this coming calvin
stands up he uses his thumb to flip a
coin into the air on the way down he
grabs it and smacks it on the back of
his opposing hand calvin smiles the team
has been making their decisions based on
the flip of a coin which introduced
randomness into their actions that even
this super advanced mathematician could
not account for tell me where 05-11 is
demands calvin the accountant pauses
then shakes his head no if he's going to
die either way then why give any
information to the kill squad kelvin
flips the coin up in the air catches it
and looks at it the coin is face up
calvin lifts his pistol and shoots the
accountant in the head a few nights
later olivia stands on a balcony outside
of an art exhibit overlooking the city
of seattle anthony walks up behind her
and tells her that the foundation is
defeated but olivia doesn't understand
how we broke the overseer's deal with
death and killed the accountant there's
nothing more to do we can go back to our
normal lives he tells her olivia is
skeptical though what about the 11th
overseer and his ability to
olivia's eyes suddenly go wide she pulls
out a knife and stabs it into anthony's
heart the world around her begins to
distort and fall apart it was a false
reality created by 05-11 better known as
the liar olivia wakes up next to adam in
a hotel room she sits up in a bed and
rubs her eyes what a weird dream she
thinks then she realizes it wasn't a
dream she shakes adam awake neither of
them have any idea how they ended up
here but they know it must be the doing
of the liar they had planned for this
though with calvin having created a
contingency plan they pull out a laptop
and log in to view the classified
information calvin left for them olivia
begins to type but stops halfway through
her password and looks up from the
screen olivia pulls out the gun that
rests under her pillow and shoots at him
the false reality created by the liar
falls apart around her olivia comes out
of the previous lie and is sitting
across the table from calvin she
immediately draws her pistol and points
it at calvin's head is it really him or
just another one of the liar's games
calvin tries to talk olivia down and she
looks around the room for
inconsistencies that might tip her off
that this is another lie but doesn't
find any olivia begins to relax she
tells calvin that the liar is trying to
get something from her maybe the journal
can tell them what he is looking for as
long as she still has it olivia nods her
head and holds out her wrist where a
subdermal chip with a copy of the
journal on it has been placed calvin
looks at her wrist the world around them
begins to dissipate as calvin morphs
into the liar olivia wakes up in a
hospital where she is hooked up to an iv
sitting across from her is a former
insurgency agent named sam beal he
explains to her that he is the liar he
was forced into becoming a monster by
the foundation they had manipulated him
but now he is tired of running and can't
do it anymore she is free to go olivia
hesitantly unhooks herself from the iv
she walks out of the hospital room and
proceeds down a fluorescent-lit hallway
as she walks away she hears a gunshot
from the hospital room as olivia's in
the hospital calvin and adam walk
through a dense forest they are
searching for 05-10 the journal
indicates that the 10th overseer's
identity within the foundation is the
archivist in the middle of the clearing
are two saplings standing side by side
the void between the sapling shimmers
coven walks through the portal and the
space begins to warp and twist around
him his vision finally comes back into
focus and calvin finds himself in
another world
adam enters the world behind calvin
practically knocking him over as he
enters through the portal
this is the wanderer's library but it
doesn't look anything like they expected
instead of rows of books the library is
filled with computer mainframes humming
with the collected knowledge of how to
contain anomalies a critical backup
as the two look intently at the strange
machines a figure in a silver robe
suddenly steps out of the darkness it's
tall and thin and though its hood is
pulled down so they can't see its face
they can see that its hands are covered
in scales that have a slight emerald
tint
it is one of the librarians calvin tells
the librarian that they are seeking the
archivist but the librarian tells them
that the archivist is no longer in the
library she has broken her pact with the
serpent and eaten fruit from the
forbidden trees
if they want to see her though the
librarian can take them to her
calvin and adam follow the librarian
down a long staircase passing by
countless doors filled with books
scrolls works of art an entire universe
of knowledge
eventually they reach the bottom of the
stairs where there stands a giant set of
brass doors
beyond the door the librarian explains
is the source of all knowledge
before calvin and adam pass through the
doors though calvin turns to the
librarian before we go in i'd like to
make a withdrawal he says the librarian
nods and pulls out a silver tube out of
its row it hands the tube to adam and he
looks it over in his hands he looks up
to ask what this is but the librarian
has vanished the door then opens and the
two step through
calvin and adam feel as if they walk
through the same kind of portal that
brought them to the library and find
that they have walked into a lush green
valley with two trees
sitting underneath one of them is a
woman in a white dress she is reading a
book and eating a piece of fruit
are you the archivist calvin asks the
woman nods yes and that's all the
confirmation calvin needs he raises his
pistol and fires but the bullet passes
right through the archivist as if she
wasn't there do you read the archivis
asked calvin seemingly not phased by his
attempts to shoot her i haven't had much
time recently calvin replied the
archivist explains that she's read every
book in the library the collected
knowledge of the universe is in the
books even one on how to allow bullets
to pass through your body she came here
to find the secret to immortality it's
her job to document everything that
happens in the world and she can't do
that if she's dead
she explains that she figured out that
the fruit that the serpent forbade
everyone to eat wasn't actual fruit but
the knowledge contained in the library
by having read every book she has
consumed the fruit
she no longer needs the serpent because
she was the serpent
the archivist falls to the ground and
begins to ride around contorting her
body as it starts to change she begins
to elongate as her limbs seemingly
disappear the next thing calvin and adam
know they are face to face with a giant
snake
calvin dodges as the serpent lunges at
him and adam stands in the doorway
firing at the snake with his pistol but
just like with the archivist's human
form the bullets have no effect the
serpent coils around calvin and begins
to choke the life from him as adam can
only watch helpless
calvin cries out with his last breath
the tube adam open the tube
adam takes the tube that was given to
him by the librarian and opens the cap a
long heavy spear slides out that looks
much too large to have ever fit inside
he drops the tube to the ground and
watches in amazement as it starts to
transform turning into what looks like a
large harpoon gun adam knows what to do
and places the giant spear into the gun
and points it at the serpent
you can't kill me
the giant snake says i've eaten from the
tree of life adam pulls the trigger and
the huge spear flies through the air
striking the serpent in the head adam
runs to calvin and helps him to his feet
they turn to look at the snake but
instead of the menacing creature it's
the archivist once again pinned against
the tree she once sat under the spear
sticking out of her skull
as the two stand looking at the
archivist a tall hooded humanoid figure
steps out from behind the tree it looks
similar to the librarian except its robe
is a greenish color and it wears long
black gloves the creature pulls the
spear out of the archivist whose body
slumps to the ground and hands the spear
to calvin
who are you calvin asks but his question
is ignored
after a moment the figure finally speaks
that spear you'll now hold is called the
spear of the non-believer it is an
ancient weapon used to kill guards it is
odd that someone in this realm gave you
the spear
even with it i'm not sure you will be
able to complete your quest carving
lucien but we shall see
there is a sudden flash of light and
calvin and adam find themselves
transported back to the forest they had
entered the wanderers library from
a week later calvin and anthony track
down 05-9 who in the council is known as
the outsider she isn't hard to find and
it seems as if she actually wanted to be
found they find her sitting outside of
her burnt down family home the journal
had listed this as her address but
calvin doubted that she would be here
and most he hoped to find a clue to her
whereabouts but here she was
sitting in the ashes of her home without
turning around the outsider began
speaking the council just used me you
know she says they took away my academic
career my friends and my life they made
me conduct research for them that
compromised everything i stood for and
now here i am with nothing the outsider
lets out a sigh she asks calvin if he's
afraid of death calvin shakes his head
and responds now the outsider slumps
forward and kelvin walks around to face
her she is covered in blood her eyes
move to look up at calvin you're lying
she says as she dies from self-inflicted
wounds calvin and anthony cross 05-9 off
the list and head back to the car as
they walk anthony says what's been on
everyone's minds the last few days the
easy part is done we'll only get harder
from here we know 05-8 is in his castle
i'm sure we'll get in but i'm not sure
if we'll make it out alive i know
replies calvin but if we're going to
save the world we must eliminate the
rest of the overseers even if it means
sacrificing our own lives they get in
the car and drive off into the blood red
sunset to pick up the rest of the kill
squad team before their next mission the
end of the world is a topic as old as
the world itself as long as we have
lived we've realized that this all has
to come to an end someday it is just a
question of when of how and of whether
there's anything we can do about it
there are thousands upon thousands of
different interpretations of how exactly
it will all come to an end some say it
ends with a bang a massive flood a
plague of locusts a rain of fire some
say it ends with a whimper the quiet
death of all life the stars winking out
all at once the world going to sleep one
day and never waking back up so how does
it all end well like many great
tragedies achilles fell by a single
arrow a tiny tremor becoming a deadly
tsunami or a tiny molecule bringing the
n for billions it begins with something
small something seemingly insignificant
it begins with a lock in 1654 a minor
scottish aristocrat named sir edwin
young was traveling across the
mesopotamian desert in search of
something most unusual he was eager to
find a new item for his cabinet of
curiosities a room in his home filled
with bizarre discoveries from all around
the globe sculptures of twisted beasts
pickled creatures gazing lifelessly from
jars and jewels plucked from the likely
cursed tombs of long dead royalty on
this particular trip he found his
favorite item yet which he describes in
his journals as a bound jewel of onyx
and filigree gold of finest beyond
rational statement it was found in an
ancient ruin thought to be the temple of
a fearsome death god though sir young
seemed to understand the gravity of his
discovery he had no idea what he had
found or that it was yet another world
altering instance of
scp-001 scp-001
is a complicated topic one we've covered
on here many times before every time you
think you understand exactly what it
means there's a new curve ball coming
directly at your face there are
nightmarish monsters a sun that's turned
against all human life more secret
origins for the foundation and perhaps
all life than you can even count on your
fingers a guardian with a flaming sword
a great red monarch hoping to bring an
end to all light and happiness in the
multiverse and now there's
scp-001 the lock or quantum's proposal
after young's death his descendants
donated his collection to the scottish
national museum there a curator named mr
mccandlish was able to translate runic
sketches in young's notes identified as
tertiary sumerian cuneiform circa 3400
bce though they could not be fully
translated the words with loss apgrt
ending joy and permanence were
identified in 2003 the scp foundation
discovered the item and brought it in
for further study the lock is a small
smooth black ellipsodial onyx stone with
a white pattern that resembles the
cosmic microwave background a pattern of
microwaves mapped by nasa that
encompasses the entire known universe
the stone is wrapped in complex layers
of gold filigree which cover the stone's
center as well as both the top and
bottom at the top of the stone the
pattern of the gold becomes too complex
for the human eye to grasp and even
defies resolution using a microscope
this is thought to be the keyhole as it
were or the point at which the lock
could become unlocked the thing about
locks is that they tend to hold secrets
they almost always have something
valuable to hide and anything that can
be locked can be unlocked as long as you
have the right key the foundation tried
a variety of methods to open the lock
with no success ordinary lock picking
techniques were futile as were attempts
to open it with a hammer chisel
sledgehammer bolt cutters welding torch
or bandsaw extreme heat industrial
cutting lasers car crushers acid plastic
explosives and even an atomic warhead
had no effect whatsoever dr hack
terminated efforts to unlock the lock
also known as project pluto on the
grounds that it was a fool's errand
better at wasting foundation resources
than producing productive results
however dr miersky who took over the
research team after dr hack's departure
resumed the project they should have
stopped trying to open it perhaps if
they had known what was waiting to be
released what app had truly meant they
would have in the lowest most secure
levels of site 10 dr yara mirsky held
the lock in her gloved hands feeling its
heat pulsed through the latex she was
inspecting the intricate gold filigree
looking at the place where a key should
fit and pondering their many attempts to
unlock it nothing had worked yet and
perhaps that was for the best though her
colleagues were uncomfortable with the
idea of something that could not be
unlocked a code that refused to be
cracked she had the distinct feeling
that an item that couldn't be opened by
even the blast of a nuclear weapon might
be hiding something even deadlier but
she didn't have time to finish that
thought a horn blared shattering her
concentration and alerting her to the
coming disaster it was a warning a sign
that something had breached containment
only it wasn't something trying to break
out it was something breaking in
hurriedly she sat down the lock and
opened a hatch in the floor removing a
harpoon gun outfitted especially for
taking on powerful anomalous entities
she knew that the harbinger was coming
there was little else she knew about the
thing but she was certain that it was
here for the lock here to open and usher
in whatever would come after she loaded
the bolt into her harpoon gun and
prepared for its arrival then all at
once there it was
glowing with brilliant white light
almost too bright to look at it was
shaped like a human being but she
couldn't see its face she couldn't look
at it for too long without her
headaching a hundred wings sprouted from
its back like a biblical angel it's
light permeating the once dimly lit
chamber she was a researcher not trained
for combat but there was no other choice
when she was all that stood between the
lock and this otherworldly being she
closed her eyes tight and she squeezed
the trigger the bolt flew and plunged
directly into the being's chest the
harbinger watched her though she could
not see its eyes she felt its gaze
boring into her as it reached up with
one hand and broke the harpoon into
pieces like it was nothing it tossed the
pieces to the side now useless not
knowing what else to do overcome with
awe and terror dr mirsky collapsed onto
her knees cut that out the harbinger
said urging her back to her feet it
promised that it would not kill her as
she stared open mouth to produce a small
simple object a key dr miersky pleaded
with the being asking it to reconsider
to think about what might be waiting
inside the lock if the harbinger had a
visible mouth it would have smiled it
told her that it knew exactly what was
inside it was epcot and it would be
released as she watched helpless the
harbinger pushed the key into the lock
and turned there was a flash of light
unbearably bright and quick the feeling
of everything changed across the world
all at once suddenly the being before
her was not a creature of wings and
light but a person a person she almost
recognized but couldn't like the
harbinger had a hold of her mind and
wouldn't let her access the memory sorry
nothing personal it said as its form
shifted back to that painful brilliance
what did you do dr miersky asked what
did you unlock what's apcat the
harbinger answered simply it is the end
soon after dr miersky met the harbinger
and watched it open the lock a man named
freddy jones was hunting snakes near
tampa florida a one thousand dollar
prize had been promised to the man who
killed the longest python and fifteen
hundred dollars were guaranteed to the
man who killed more pythons than anyone
else just days before freddy had been
filling up his truck at the local gas
and go when he stopped to watch the
longest python he had ever seen in his
life slither across the asphalt and into
the nearby swamp that was a surefire way
to win if he'd ever seen one and now he
was making his way across the wet
springy ground of the swamp in search of
his prize after two hours of trampling
through the wilderness all he had to
show for it was a few king snakes and
some black racers no pythons yet and
certainly not the extra-long beasts he'd
seen before he was getting close to
giving up hot exhausted covered in bites
from fire ants when he saw it smooth
scaly skin winding through the
underbrush he'd know that pattern
anywhere he snapped back into hunter
mode trailing the creature as fast as he
could his heart thumped against his
chest and he reminded himself his
cardiologist said to avoid strenuous
exercise but he had already come this
far no giving up now his father hadn't
raised a quitter above him a storm was
brewing thick clouds gathering as
thunder shook the ground and lightning
flashed uncomfortably close he had to
move fast there was no doubt about it
his time out there was limited he was
right about this but not for the reason
he thought he stumbled as the ground
quaked trying to keep on his feet the
python was still in his eye line looking
longer and bigger as he got closer he
weaved through the tall grass looking
for the snake's head he took six steps
then six more there was no sign of its
head yet this thing was even bigger than
he thought no way anyone else was taking
home that cash he felt his stomach drop
as he realized he still couldn't find
the snake's head its body stretched on
and on weaving all around the brush it
was everywhere and it was somehow
growing he pointed his rifle at one side
where the snake's body had grown to the
size of a horse that was impossible he
had to have been seeing things but there
it was he squeezed the trigger and fired
the sound lost in the thunder the snake
didn't even react it grew larger and
thicker winding around him as he turned
in circles trying to track it he didn't
even see the enormous head rising over
him at least until it blocked out the
sun he opened his mouth to scream but
was crushed beneath the body of the
massive snake as it slithered through
the swamp crushing plants and animals as
it went freddy jones was not the only
person to see something strange at that
moment and he would not be the last a
change was coming and it was coming
faster than anyone could keep up with in
south dakota the king of the bears
clawed his way up from the earth with
paws the size of trucks a massive beast
from the deep crushed a tour boat off
the shores of new england a buffalo the
size of a mountain shook itself awake on
the great plains across the world from
above and below and beyond it something
was coming an unknowable number of
things in fact entities from beyond the
stars from the ocean floor from the
earth's crust and mouse holes in
provincial homes there was some that
loved humanity some that hated it some
that could barely remember what it was
another was from the scp foundation
itself someone who is not supposed to
exist none of them were really but they
all did and they were all coming to see
what would happen next this story is
only just beginning because it wasn't
just one apocalypse that was unleashed
with the opening of the lock it was
all of them
the aurabora cycle one of the biggest
most legendary series of entries in the
history of the scp foundation we've
covered the events of this scp-001 epic
in six videos which we definitely
recommend you watch before this one to
avoid your brain exploding from the
sheer scope of it all because that's the
thing about the orborus cycle it's a
story so big sprawling and dense that it
can feel almost like an anomaly itself
whether you're immersed in the possible
origin of the broken god the sentient
black hole that can destroy the whole
universe or calvin lucian's quest to
assassinate the o5 council it can
sometimes be difficult to see the forest
from the trees but worry not because
that's exactly why we're here today
we're going to step back and look at
this anomalous odyssey as a whole and
ask the big question why is it all here
together what makes these four different
storylines the children the broken god
atonement and the way it ends one big
cycle as with anything involving the scp
foundation there's always going to be an
element of personal interpretation but
now that we've gone through the whole
cycle we think it's worth adding our two
cents to the proceedings so let's start
broad a question you've probably been
wondering is what do the words orbora
cycle actually mean and what is their
significance to the four stories within
while the spelling can differ orboros
refers to the ancient symbol of a snake
or dragon eating its own tail forming a
circle a direct connection to the
concept of cycles the arbor symbol has
existed in a huge number of cultures
from the ancient egyptians to the
ancient greeks to modern gnostic
traditions it's often used in alchemy or
other magical practices and has a
variety of meanings such as eternal life
the endless cycle of death and rebirth
and the cycle of renewal anyone familiar
with the tales within the orbora cycle
is probably already noticing some
similarities cycles are a common theme
in all of these works people endlessly
repeat mistakes threats thought to be
contained or destroyed return and often
times those who go out on a quest to
destroy something end up becoming what
they wish to destroy in the first place
in a cycle there is no true end and no
true beginning everything repeats
endlessly but let's start at the closest
thing to the beginning we have the
children in this tale the foundation
faces off against a terrifying reality
warping group of interests known as the
kingdom of abaddon this nasty group
which came from the sahara desert could
seemingly take anything the foundation
threw at them and were able to straight
up vaporize anyone who got too close if
the kingdom was able to amass enough
power it could spell the end of the
foundation and even the subjugation of
the human race enter 05-1 a reoccurring
character in the arboros cycle this
outside the box thinker put all his
chips on the twins of god project
designated
scp-001 like many anomalies before and
after it this project would infuse a
human being with godlike powers but it
was a power so great that it seemed to
kill anyone who attempted to accept it
needless to say this was a major bummer
for o5-1 but through relentless human
experimentation even sacrificing the
population of entire towns to the
project he eventually came up with a
solution a horrifying solution but a
solution nonetheless he found that a
group of nine children with ages varying
from four to eleven could act as a human
conduit for zero zero one's power and as
a result it could be a weapon capable of
turning the tide against the kingdom of
abaddon during the testing phase though
it'd seem like 05-1 went a little mad
with power he vaporized an entire church
of the broken god place of worship and
used the power of the children to wipe a
few others off the map at his own
discretion his abuses of power got so
flagrant that the administrator himself
was called in to get a handle on the
situation and surprise surprise 0-5-1
disintegrated him two before
disappearing himself shortly afterwards
in the end the children were deemed too
dangerous to be practical both because
of their anomalous powers and from the
level of ambient radiation they put out
all nine were locked in radiation-proof
boxes and buried in the desert though
they each show signs of life to this day
while this may seem disconnected from
the rest of the series it actually
establishes some of the most important
reoccurring themes and ideas of this
cycle as a whole namely the foundation
messing with reality and performing
horrific acts to achieve their goals the
corruption of the o5 council and the
fact that these grand attempts to change
or save the world often blow up in
everyone's faces sometimes literally we
also have the introduction and apparent
death of the mysterious administrator
but trust us all is not what it seems
with this one the ripple effect
beginning here will affect everything
going forward next the broken god this
tells the chaotic story of a magical
clockwork box which is worshiped by the
church of the broken god as a conduit to
their deity and eventually becomes an
all-devouring mechanical kaiju the beast
soon dubbed
scp-001 devoured and consumed all the
metal around it slowly becoming larger
and more destructive if the foundation
didn't take it out before it reached
critical mass they'd be going toe to toe
with a bona fide god a fight they really
weren't sure they could win thankfully
and with a little anomalous help from
scp-2399
the foundation was able to destroy the
anomaly they removed its clockwork heart
from the wreckage and contained the
anomalous crap that once comprised its
destructive body however the foundation
soon realized that you just can't keep a
good god down the clockwork heart
eventually evaded foundation containment
while being shipped to a secondary
location and instead ended up in a small
town here it began to influence the
minds of the residents into more
subservient broken god cultists intent
on building him back up to his former
glory it'd be easy to discount the
broken god as an outlier seeing as the
foundation came out looking much better
here than they do in any of the other
orboros tales but when you look
carefully its place in the overall cycle
is clear the entry ends the way it
begins with the heart of the broken god
influencing humans to carry out its
bidding the foundation had to intervene
in between these two instances but in
the end there was no net loss to the
broken god itself in a sense the
foundation is doomed to encounter the
same problems again and again
continually defending the world from the
same anomalous threats and the
foundation needs to succeed every time
to maintain peace and normality a major
anomalous threat only needs to succeed
once to drag everything into disarray in
many ways that is the curse of the scp
foundation speaking of major anomalous
threats now it's time for part 3 of the
orboro cycle atonement once again we
start off with the foundation meddling
with cosmic scale powers with the
creation of the area 11 pietro cal
fontaine spatial stabilization array try
saying that three times fast that was a
machine so powerful it was capable of
creating a singularity though what it
actually ended up doing was turning dr
calvin desmond into an abomination more
specifically into a kind of immensely
powerful humanoid black hole whose
powers were only restrained by the very
machine that created him think of him as
kind of a malicious dr manhattan from
watchmen this new entity dubbed scp-001
presented a grim prophecy and an ominous
offer he told the o5 council that
anomalies were leaking into their
universe from other realities and soon
the anomalous threat would destroy them
all his offer was to upon his release
wipe out the rest of the multiverse
entirely leaving only our reality free
from anomalous threats
unsurprisingly it was 05-1 that was most
interested in this offer so much so that
he held a vote and murdered everyone who
voted against the decision to release
scp-001 having built his consensus among
the survivors on the council 05-1 let
scp-001 out unsurprisingly this turned
out to be a terrible decision as one of
his first acts upon being freed was to
kill the members of the o5 council that
had just voted to release 001 saying
that they themselves were anomalous and
needed to be purged to atone for their
past sins the only survivor was a member
of the council who abstained from the
vote who was able to recontain scp-001
inside the petrichow fontaine array for
now once again the thematic connections
to the rest of the orboro cycle is clear
we have a world-ending anomaly held off
but only temporarily buying time before
the cycle inevitably continues we have
the foundation abusing its power and
signing off on the death of countless
people in other dimensions and of course
the o5 council stepped out of their
bounds and actively warped reality just
like they had with the children before
their chickens truly come home to roost
though in the final part of the cycle
appropriately named the way it ends this
piece chronicles the story of calvin
lucian and the kill squad an elite group
of four chaos insurgency soldiers with
one goal assassinating the entire o5
council 13 of the most powerful people
in the world why because they've been
messing with reality itself time and
time again and it's getting to the point
that their selfish meddling could
finally destroy everything and given
that we've already seen it happen with
the children and the entity that dr
calvin desmond became it's hard to
disagree with them what follows is one
of the longest and most complicated
tales in all of the foundation as the
kill squad systematically encounters and
kills each insane anomalous member of
the o5 council in order to do this they
need to make deals with death itself
fight giant serpents cross dimensions
deal with scp-610 and scp-682
containment breaches and go toe-to-toe
with samsara arguably the foundation's
deadliest mobile task force a number of
other insane things happen along the way
like 05-1 murdering the gate guardian
with the scranton reality anchor and the
black queen the most prominent member of
the serpent's hand helping our heroes
defeat more over sears in the end calvin
lucian despite losing almost everything
reigns victorious in the final battle
using the spear of the non-believer a
weapon so powerful it can kill gods
calvin managed to finally kill the top
member of the overseers
05-1 with the o5 council destroyed
calvin set about completing his final
task destroying the entire scp
foundation but that didn't happen
instead he was contacted by a mysterious
and immensely powerful being known as
the administrator who gave him some
frightening news he'd just been hired by
the scp foundation to be their new
05-1 this was where our last video on
the arborist series left us what happens
next you may ask how does calvin respond
to this offer he seemingly can't refuse
in this case it seems that the
administrator of being so completely
tied to the nature of the foundation
itself is
scp-001 and while it seemed that the
overseers were mad with power they were
actually always there to keep the
administrator in check aaron siegler the
05-1 that calvin had just killed was
doing the exact same thing calvin was
doing when he became 05-1
trying to destroy the foundation but the
foundation and the administrator cannot
be beaten they can only be joined and
that's exactly what calvin did becoming
the new 05-1 turning his back on the
chaos insurgency and rebuilding the rest
of the council and the foundation in his
own image insurgency members who were
once his allies vowed revenge for this
betrayal perhaps suggesting that history
would go on to repeat itself once more
in the future because at the end of the
day that's what the oboro cycle really
is the reoccurring threat and the
changing of the guards that accompanies
it there will always be a foundation
there will always be an administrator
there will always be an 05 council
nothing starts nothing ends all that
ever changes are the names and faces
involved whether it's calvin lucian or
aaron siegler the wheel keeps turning
the snake devours its own tail the obora
cycle is and forever will be eternal
they came from beyond the world from
over the world from under the world they
came from inside the stars and from
behind the rain they came from the known
lands and they came from the secret
places of old the vast ones who drank of
the nebulae the small ones who did not
care what happened beyond the banks of
their rivers the ones who bathed in the
light and the ones who watched from the
shadows the ones who loved us and the
ones who forgot about us the ones who
hate us now and the ones who love us
still the ones who sung with the rats
and the ones who swam with the
leviathans they came from far and near
they came one and all
they came to end the world as you may
already know from our previous video in
this series a mysterious being known
only as the harbinger unlocked scp-001
the lock and brought about the
omnipocalypse every single
world-destroying xk-class scenario on
the books from foundation files to the
most ancient mythological tomes and some
we'd never even imagined began to come
true a world flooded with terrifying
anomalous activity from unfurling skies
to giant nightmarish animals was about
where we left off now it's time to open
your eyes and wake up this is the kind
of nightmare you can't encounter while
you're asleep
scp-5720 the astronomically inclined
crane went about its daily work the
small mechanical crane always occupied
itself with the one task that gave its
existence any meaning arranging esoteric
model solar systems but something was
different today
scp-5720 put the final touches on its
latest model and then lifted its
mechanical arm skywards pointing
directly into the vast and starry
infinity above but were they stars no
not today as
scp-5720 looked up at the sky this time
the sky looked back they weren't stars
they were eyes something was coming
towards earth from the furthest reaches
of the outer dark an armada of world
enders coming from above below and all
around a whole cosmos of supremely
powerful beings zeroing in on our pale
blue dot a thought crossed through
whatever passed as the mind of this
strange little crane today
followed by another word ringing loud
and clear and holy as a mighty church
bell
and at that moment everything did
thousands of miles away a new god landed
on earth appearing like a great wall of
dense matted fur descending from the sky
ur on um the mother of the ones that
came before after eons of absence she
had eventually returned to greet her
children the true rulers and stewards of
this land but er on um was surprised and
horrified by what she saw their great
cities their sprawling structures their
beautiful art and advanced culture all
gone laid to waste by the worthless
hairless apes that once lurked in the
forests with the other animals something
had happened something
had changed the humans had slaughtered
her people destroyed their
accomplishments tarnished their legacy
driven the few that were left out of
their kingdoms and into the forests
treated them as mere animals and built
their hideous concrete cities over their
bones and they had the gall to call them
bigfoot or scp-1000
because thanks to them their beautiful
true name had been lost to time she
looked skywards and cried out in despair
and anguish at the loss of her children
inconsolable but then she felt something
a glimmer of hope in her mind the
possibility that things would change
that the humans would be toppled from
their thrones and true justice would be
achieved she called out to her remaining
children and her children answered
across the globe another great entity
awoke deep underneath a mountain when it
stirred into life and broke free it
shattered the entire mountain on top of
it as easily as you or me displacing a
bed sheet it took to the skies massive
but unseeable to the human eye it soared
through the air gazing down upon the
world it hadn't seen for thousands of
years once it had feasted on the blood
sacrifices of human subjects hoping to
avoid its wrath but humans weren't the
petty little group of huddled cavemen
that they had once been now they were in
their billions gathered in impossibly
large settlements the entity sought to
find a seat of power that it could
influence but now it was spoiled for
choice eventually it zeroed in and found
its perfect target an scp foundation
containment site here it would find a
new form to take and more petty pathetic
humans to bring under its mighty thrall
it landed in scp-765
the duck pond it is an anomalous pond
that is you guessed it full of ducks and
initially induces feelings of serenity
in its victims before later inducing not
so pleasant feelings when the entity
plummeted into the water it began to
absorb and bond with the anomaly growing
to epic sizes as it assumed a form that
the minds of us feeble humans could
comprehend a giant terrifying duck it
released a mighty earth-shaking quack as
it plodded across the countryside to
cause mayhem elsewhere in europe more
violent madness was unfolding a crimson
rooster cod then a golden rooster and
then a rooster of soot red anyone with a
basic knowledge of norse mythology was
shaking in their boots as a mighty beast
stirred in the heart of a desolate cave
the chains that had once held the
monstrous dog in place now broke it rose
and licked its jagged fangs excited to
stain them with the blood of its enemies
it was the great hound fener omen of the
end times here to herald the end of all
things a trumpet boomed across the globe
with no apparent source people in the
streets in new york delhi london cape
town and countless other towns cities
and hamlets the world over paused and
listened in confusion below them the
great and terrible jormungar the thought
to be mythological midgard serpent
stirred from its previously eternal
slumber and began to uncoil its body the
shifting caused earthquakes and tsunamis
along the coast of greenland as towns
and villages crumbled killing thousands
fenrir stalked along the length of
denmark slaughtering and devouring
anyone or anything unlucky enough to
cross its path but it did not wage its
war against mankind alone behind it a
hellish army of burning giants marched
mighty hands clutching molten weapons
ragnarok was upon us now odin save us
all and the administrator
slept she was the latest in a long line
of foundation staff members to hold that
hollowed position and in the dark vistas
of her dreams a predecessor approached
her he wasn't the old bearded man in the
heavy coat that she remembered now he
was wearing a 1950 suit and a fedora hat
and carrying a briefcase that's right
he'd taken up the mantle of scp-990
also known as the dream man he's a
mysterious figure that appears to
members of the foundation in their
dreams warning them of impending
disasters that they may be able to
narrowly prevent if his warning is
heated though it often comes at some
terrible cost to the recipient of his
message this time however his message
carried a different tone he told the
current administrator that there was no
way to stop the apocalypse from
occurring this time only making sure
that the particular shape of the
apocalypse would be the one most
favorable to the foundation and
humanity's joint interests all this was
devastating news that the new
administrator saw as a grievous betrayal
of both the foundation stances and
humanity as a whole she refused to
accept the idea that the apocalypse was
inevitable even coming from the mouth of
a former administrator as far as she was
concerned this dream man no longer
worked on the side of the foundation he
was in league with the world enders and
she refused to take his deal the scp
foundation would save this world from
the horrors the lock unleashed or they
would slide into the darkness with it
they would never work against the human
race scp-343
also known as god awoken his cell in
site-17 the time for fun and games with
the humans at the foundation had come
and gone he was going by his true name
yahweh now he blinked and in that same
instant he was at site zero the
containment site for another scp-001
the legendary gate guardian all the
staff around them looked upon yahweh in
shock awed by the reality warper's
sudden appearance and unable to do
anything about it but really 343 was no
mere reality warper like some had
expected 343 truly was a god he just
didn't happen to be the only one in play
when the gate guardian saw yahweh now
standing before him he lowered his sword
spread his fiery wings and took a knee
in great reverence yahweh spoke calmly
but with unshakable authority
it is time
open the gate
lead my armies across the earth
the gate guardian uriel responded in its
booming voice
for the first time in recorded memory
the grand gate that uriel had always
been guarding opened revealing thousands
of legions of warrior angels waiting on
the other side they were impossibly
beautiful and powerful creatures each
won a vibrant glowing chaos of wings and
eyes wielding pure white swords and
singing resounding hymns of war soon the
air was thick with the chorus of
rustling wings as the angels loosened
themselves from the gate's mouth led by
yurio as yahweh's general into the
global fray meanwhile back at site 10
another scp-001
the item that started all of this the
walk was entering its next stage of
grand cosmic evolution something within
the lock suddenly unfurled causing a
shockwave that killed everyone at the
site and destroying the entire building
in an instant except in that same
instant all of the site 10 staff and the
building itself reappeared completely
unharmed in a field in new hampshire
back where site 10 used to be the lock
was doing some terraforming the ground
split open beneath into a mighty valley
the likes of which earth had never seen
before lush greenery sprouted within and
thousands of strange alien creatures
soon populated this new place in the
center the lock just floated in place
they were now ready for the first
meeting to take place over at site 2036
dr everett mann was working on a number
of
scp-098 specimens these are frightening
creatures reminiscent of spider crabs
with blades instead of pinchers and a
natural ability to mimic the sounds of
their prey he was studying the creatures
when he got a call asking him if the
specimens had acted up at all they had
already had sudden containment breaches
for scp-995
a type of dangerous carnivorous fungi
and scp-616
a mysterious airplane with satanic
elements to it just as dr mann was about
to reply the 098 specimens
metamorphosized into many winged flying
creatures which flew out of the chamber
with such force that they busted through
walls sirens blared all through the
facility and dr mann joined the many
other confused and frustrated foundation
staff members wandering the building
wondering just what the hell was going
on today they were getting bizarre
reports of unprecedented anomalous
activity from all over the world with no
explanation uniting at all according to
panicked whispers across the facility
emergency order patmos was now in effect
whatever that meant the true nature of
what was going on here went over most of
the heads of the scp foundation's staff
that's when man encountered dr charles
ogden gears who for such a famously
emotionless man looks surprisingly
worried dr mann tried to downplay the
situation saying they were only looking
at a handful of containment breaches
here nothing they hadn't handled before
dr gears shut him down with trademark
coldness feeling a little more nervous
now dr everett mann asked what else had
gotten out with steely eyes dr gears
replied
a whole damn lot congratulations
you did it after years of working your
fingers to the bone at the legendary scp
foundation putting your life sanity and
perhaps even immortal soul at risk every
single day you suddenly find yourself
standing at the very tip of the pyramid
you can now learn about the truth behind
scp-001
you'd be lying if you said it was an
easy journey you started about one rung
above d-class a mere janitor mopping
hallways and cleaning toilets for
personnel who actually got a piece of
the action not that it meant you didn't
have to experience risk on the job you
remembered one of the most terrifying
moments of your life occurred during
this period back when you were just
cleaning out office space in site 19 you
heard the door rattle behind you and you
rose back up just in time to see
scp-173 standing in the doorway staring
at you you heard about this thing about
how you had to keep your eyes on it or
it would kill you and then everything
else you stared at it eyes watering in
panic hoping to keep it rooted in place
but it was starting to hurt you could
feel yourself straining the surface of
your eyes was so dry was this where you
were going to die perhaps if you hadn't
had the idea you had next you blinked
one eye and then the other keeping one
eye open at all times that kept the
sculpture in place long enough for the
site's security team to locate it and
drag it back to containment you'd saved
your own life and many others that day
and decided in that moment that you may
really have a future here and you
weren't the only one with this level of
confidence hearing about your quick
thinking and heroic bravery the head of
the site security team decided you might
be an ideal candidate for his crew after
the proper training you jumped at the
chance of course to experience the
grueling barrage of physical and mental
courses needed to survive and thrive
under the pressure of being a dedicated
foundation guard before long you became
an accepted member of the security team
and you'd go on to receive further
commendations for your cool-headedness
and bravery during dangerous containment
breaches from
scp-3199
scp-106 and
scp-939 respectively you were quickly
turning into a respected figure among
your foundation peers while some would
be content to coast on that you'd never
been the kind of person who just rests
on their laurels by day you work to keep
site 19 safe from deadly containment
breaches and infiltration from crafty
groups of interests like the chaos
insurgency and the serpent's hand but by
night you were taking online college
courses slowly beefing up your
qualifications in a number of esoteric
research sciences after years of hard
work you requested a transfer from
senior security officer to junior
researcher it'd be a step backwards in
terms of career advancement and you were
also told you'd be getting a pay cut for
your trouble but you didn't care you'd
even start with archival work if it
meant getting closer to the actual
anomalies the foundation was all about
so that's exactly what happened you were
made a junior researcher and your first
job was archival duties sorting and
digitizing years of files with a new
computerized system for some this would
be hell for you
it's heaven you're getting to see it all
up close the deepest darkest secrets of
the scp foundation well
not quite at your low clearance level
there's only a certain amount you're
able to access even when filing things
away stumbling into the wrong files and
attempting to access them can be
actively dangerous too as many of them
are protected with the kind of heavy
duty memetic kill agents that stop your
heart before you'd even have a chance to
click away but funnily enough that level
of protection only made the forbidden
fruit of knowledge seem more enticing
and the very peak of curiosities locked
under so many layers of secrecy and
encryption was the equal parts iconic
and infamous
scp-001 some senior researchers had
spread rumors about the true nature of
zero zero one but nobody truly had the
full scope of it outside of the o5
council for pretty much everyone else
the true answers would be forever out of
reach like a distant but enrapturing
mirage and it was at that moment that
you decided you'd simply have to become
a member of the 05 council and for the
rest of your life that's exactly what
you were trying to work towards after
all rumor has it that the council has
access to secret life-extending
anomalies that they use to linger around
for centuries a single meager lifetime
working toward a seat at that table
would be such a small price to pay when
all was said and done for the next few
decades you did everything you could to
advance your position and climb through
the ranks of this prestigious
organization you published award-winning
research papers on the nature of
thomatology you worked multiple 18-hour
shifts a week getting up close and
personal with some of the most famous
and dangerous anomalies on the books
scp-106
scp-096
and even scp-682
you showed bravery and heroism during
containment breaches staying calm and
keeping the people around you out of
harm's way and as you rise through the
ranks you always kept your goal in mind
you'll uncover the secrets of scp-001
you have to know you will know there is
no other acceptable outcome while
technically speaking 0.001 is above
classified the scp foundation is an
organization run by humans well mostly
anyway and when humans are involved
nothing will ever be infallible and
after all there's no such thing as a
perfect seal when you're rubbing elbows
with dr gears dr clef and dr bright it's
natural that some things start to slip
out in conversation even if strictly
speaking it's in defiance of official
foundation protocol but something
strikes you as very strange as each one
tells you about their vision of scp-001
you notice that each is describing a
completely different thing dr kleff for
example begins covertly telling you
about something known as the gate
guardian also known by the alias yurial
this being is said to act as the bouncer
at the door to paradise he is impossibly
huge with wings made of burning light
and a sword of pure fire that's hotter
than the sun cleft tells you that the
creature's sword is so powerful that it
cleaves its victims apart on the atomic
level completely and utterly destroying
every trace of them though he then
grumbles with visible frustration that
it failed in its attempts to kill
scp-682 adding no surprises there right
as he left to have a smoke dr bright
tells you an incredibly different story
to him scp-001
isn't a being it's a location an
expansive factory from the 19th century
that was created by pure evil occultist
and industrialist james anderson this
place initially seemed like a boon
providing jobs to the needy travelers
and transients across the early united
states but this dream come true soon
revealed itself to be a complete
nightmare anderson was a brutal
taskmaster who not only worked thousands
of people to death but performed
horrifying occult experiments on the
grounds of the cursed building you
started to worry that perhaps dr bright
had a little too much to drink when he
started ranting about how the factory
helped a burgeoning scp foundation
commit genocide against the fey but you
were happy to receive more information
about scp-001
in any case and dr gears told a far more
low-key story than the other two which
was fitting really for a man so
incredibly buttoned down he probably
thought of lucky charm marshmallows as
an almost unspeakable act of
self-indulgence he told the story of a
being he referred to as the prototype a
dangerous and radioactive monster that
functioned as the first truly
threatening creature that the scp
foundation ever faced containing it with
imperfect methods even led to the death
of dr ketter which in turn led to the
naming of the keter class for any
anomalies that were particularly
challenging to contain you were awash
with data and yet it somehow felt like
you now knew less for sure was
scp-001 some kind of umbrella term for a
vast collection of different anomalies
each one either deeply important or
somehow formative for the scp foundation
curiouser and curiouser naturally this
did nothing to deter your boundless
drive to know the true secrets of this
mysterious designation that seemed to
exist at the very heart of the scp
foundation years went on and you went
from a decorated senior researcher to
the site director for site 19. there
through even more years of hard work you
developed a reputation as one of the
greatest directors the site ever had you
reduced containment breaches by a truly
astonishing 80 percent during your
tenure and the breaches that did happen
were significantly less deadly under
your sterling management general
personnel satisfaction skyrocketed with
the people working under you both
enjoying your leadership and respecting
you enough to take you seriously you
were firm but fair a truly exemplary
site director the more you climbed the
more information about scp-008
seemed to fall into your lap the sheer
breadth of some of these concepts were
staggering the scarlet king the black
moon the lock the broken god a whole
laundry list of terrifying existential
threats hiding just under the thin crust
of normalcy just how much were they
hiding from you were they all real was
only one real and the rest in elaborate
smokescreen you just had to know but
even if it took your whole life a
40-year career with the scp foundation
putting everything at hazard for a
chance to gaze into the ultimate chest
of secrets and eventually with the
mysterious passing of a previous member
of the o5 council which as far as anyone
else knows you had nothing to do with
the position of 05-10 has opened up and
who else is next in line to that throne
but you
congratulations you made it to the next
step the big boys table and the truth
about scp-001
comes with the territory you're given an
orientation document written by a prior
05 council member known as lh sign from
the korean branch of the foundation it
promises that after you put in your new
o5 login credentials it'll tell you
everything you need to know about
scp-001
with quaking fingers you type in your
username and password and the page opens
revealing the truth about
scp-001 to your eager eyes your jaw
drops your forehead is suddenly doused
in the sheen of cold sweat no you think
this has to be a joke it can't be true
your life
your whole life building up to learning
scp-001 does not exist the document in
upsettingly plain terms explains to you
that while some of the anomalies
referred to as scp-001 do exist in some
capacity the closest funnily enough
being dr gear's story about the
prototype for the most part there is no
such thing as zero zero one and the
finer details are either entirely
fabricated or at the very least greatly
exaggerated everything you've been
working towards it was just one big
fraud perpetrated by the foundation why
you found yourself asking in a trembling
voice why why why and the answer was
simple to provoke the egos of the
foundation's personnel you see while the
foundation has always contained
anomalies that was a means to an end not
the end itself the true purpose of the
foundation is and always has been
protecting people and every anomaly
contained as more people protected
however tricking the lower rungs of the
foundation into believing that there's
some grand final boss to work towards
like a black moon or a scarlet king has
been an effective method of keeping
everyone motivated to swim in the same
direction this is hardly an
unprecedented move for the scp
foundation from their lies around
procedure 110 montauk to the controlled
deception around the rituals that
supposedly keep the devourer of worlds
on the other side of scp-2317
the scp foundation has never shed away
from lying to its own employees for the
greater good but you never expected it
to happen to you and you certainly never
expected it to be about
scp-001 you feel like you've been
laughed at for your entire life but now
you crack a quivering smile
maybe your mind has snapped or maybe
you're just glad to finally be in on the
joke
to say all hell had broken loose would
be a vast understatement a more
realistic assessment of what had
happened in the aftermath of scp-001 the
lock being opened would be
every hell had broken loose along with
every heaven every anomaly every ancient
god and buried horror every nightmare
from outer space and from different
dimensions
every agent of the apocalypse every
emissary of ragnarok every entity
sentient and otherwise with a vested
interest in seeing the world as we know
it come to an end so it goes without
saying the scp foundation and their
allies had their work cut out for them
so before we march once again into the
terrifying future let's quickly refresh
our memories as to how we got here the
lock had started off as a mere curio in
a 19th century explorer's vast
collection before it fell into the
possession of the scp foundation and
became designated as scp-001
for years the lock perplexed people with
its seemingly limitless mysteries from
its origins to its strange markings to
what would happen when the lock is
finally opened and it would indeed be
opened in perhaps the ultimate example
of be careful what you wish for an
entity known as the harbinger invaded
site 10 and used a special key to
finally open the lock triggering the
ultimate apocalypse anomalies became
more powerful and escape containment all
over the world animals mutated into
giant monsters and began causing chaos
mythological creatures such as the
goddess of
scp-1000 the mighty norse fenrir and an
entity that transformed into a giant
evil duck went totally berserk the lock
itself completely blew up site 10 before
remaking it and its personnel elsewhere
and turned the crater where site 10 used
to be into an incredible otherworldly
valley on earth where an even more
incredible meeting would soon take place
scp-990 the dream man came to the
administrator of the scp foundation and
warned her of impending doom but she
decided that no matter how dire things
got the foundation would fight back and
that brings us to the star of the show
scp-343 also known as god but please
call him yahweh no point in sticking to
formality here at the end of it all
right ever since the lock was opened by
that pesky mysterious harbinger he'd
been an extremely busy deity last time
we saw him make his long-awaited
rendezvous with another
scp-001 the gate guardian whose true
name was revealed to be yurio yahweh
instructed yuril to open the gate to
paradise releasing his armies of
powerful sword-wielding angels upon the
earth and now we're all caught up let
the madness commence after instructing
yoriel to free his armies and lead them
in a war against evil yahweh decided to
address the most powerful humans on
earth and enlist them in his fight those
same arrogant humans who foolishly
believed they'd been containing him all
this time and not that he'd simply been
choosing to stay with them perhaps now
they would see sense yahweh manifested
physically in 13 different places at
once and spoke to the o5 council they
were filled with awe and holy terror as
the deity appeared before them like a
glittering ghost eyes glowing exuding
pure power speaking with absolute
authority he said
servant once told your founder to
prepare for the great and terrible day
of the lord this day now approaches make
your final preparations there is nothing
else you will need to do but wait my
armies ride across the earth soon i will
call the four horsemen once the last
judgment has been unsealed
then shall the great and terrible day of
the lord come and then
all will have paradise
and with that he was gone leaving the
most powerful human beings on earth
shaken it was about time they got a
reality check about their true cosmic
insignificance still the act of
splitting himself 13 waves briefly gave
yahweh symptoms similar to vertigo
during his confinement he hadn't needed
to truly flex his power and now he was
finally beginning to feel the
limitations of this human form but he
didn't have time to muse over the nature
of human frailty as the world he worked
so hard on began to crumble around him
he needed to return to the valley the
precursor to eden's return the valley
where only he had set foot he breathed a
sigh and teleported there prepared to
finally be alone and collect his
thoughts but he wasn't alone you've
probably heard salicious stories about
parties getting out of hand it always
goes the same way a birthday party or
small gathering created as an event on
facebook but accidentally set to public
not long after little andrea's
quintenera or joe's bar mitzvah suddenly
has 5 000 attendees all strangers and
the riot police are called in to get the
chaos under control now imagine that
same thing but instead of rowdy
drunkards it's cosmic figures and
apocalyptic beings from all over the
multiverse and now you know what yahweh
walked in on welcome to the valley of
gods and monsters it was crowded with
beings that would boggle your mind to
even comprehend deities with two limbs
six limbs a hundred limbs or none spirit
whales and feathered snakes flew
overhead with clouds of intelligent
insects and fey flying just below a
giant furred creature moved over a
distant mountain looking on a pure black
humanoid entity appeared before yahweh
blinked and then vanished moments later
a giant centipede-like creature
skittered past him giving him a nasty
glare everyone was here the pantheon of
greek gods from zeus to hades every
egyptian god and monster the bird-headed
ra the jackal-headed anubis the
monstrous snake beast apep the norse
gods were drinking and having rowdy
conversations with the hindu deities
entities so ancient their names have
been forgotten and monsters whose faces
had only ever been seen in the restless
dreams of billions of humans then
quickly forgotten upon waking in short
the gangs all hear yahweh for the first
time ever was feeling lost confused and
even small he decided to mingle with the
crowd of humanoid gods wanting to be
with people who looked like him there he
met a dark-skinned woman with long hair
and lip piercings known as asherah
although his memory of her was faint she
reminded him that she was once his
consort back before he made the
admittedly jerk move of wiping out all
the other pantheons of history so that
he could rule over the cosmos alone but
now with the opening of the lock
everyone was back ready to cause the
apocalypse but here was the problem they
didn't just want to cause the apocalypse
they wanted to cause their apocalypse
every belief system had its own vision
for how this strange little show we
called earth should end and not all of
them were compatible so a very heated
debate was breaking out as to who should
really get to bring the world to an end
and the most darkly funny part of this
very few of these gods entities and
creatures even knew about each other
until a few moments before so the fact
that they had this level of competition
was a very unpleasant surprise to put it
in perspective imagine you're neil
armstrong circa 1969 taking the apollo
11 shuttle straight to the moon the
craft lands he's suited up preparing for
the first ever moonwalk his iconic quote
this is one small step for man one giant
leap for mankind already looping in his
head then when he steps off the craft
there are already several people on the
lunar surface lounging on deck chairs
and asking him if he'd like a beer when
he asked them what the hell is going on
they tell him they just got here an hour
ago and were making themselves
comfortable yahweh was beginning to
realize that perhaps he really didn't
hold the sway he thought he did any
bible fans in our audience will know
that the plan for the christian
apocalypse is laid out pretty clear in
the book of revelations satan armies of
angels giant scorpion locusts and in the
end the rebirth of paradise on earth
yahweh thought all things considered his
version of the end of everything
actually shook out pretty well for
everybody a little temporary hell on
earth and painful damnation aside but
here he wasn't the holiest of holies he
was just one guy with a big picture idea
alongside so many other beings each with
their own big picture designs for ending
things all except ashira she'd spent
time in a mortal form on earth and had
really grown to like the place in that
time so much so that she didn't want to
see it end in any manner in her own
words to a baffled and somewhat offended
yahweh i may have been called here but
not even that lock can make me end the
world have you ever tried the seafood in
singapore have you ever used a
smartphone ran through the jungle seen
cirque du soleil flown on an airplane
surfed the internet watched tentacle
porn seen star wars explored the
wanderers library been lost in the
concrete mazes of the new human cities
now i like the world the way it is
thinks it may be messed up but tearing
it apart isn't going to improve anything
so no i don't plan to end the world i
actually don't plan to let you end the
world either or anyone else sorry yahweh
was somewhere between enraged and amazed
his former consort was not only willing
to go against him but every cosmic being
here she was staring down the barrel of
quite literally infinite power and yet
she still stood in defiance of them
yahweh was about to retort when
something even more bizarre happened in
the valley of gods in monsters a woman's
voice rang out simply saying pardon me
in a calm even tone that somehow caught
the attention of every deity and world
ender in the valley they turned in
amazement to see a human woman in a gray
suit standing among them a face that
somehow all these supposedly all-knowing
beings couldn't seem to recognize
but if you as cp explained fans have
been perceptive in the previous videos
it's a face you'll know all too well the
administrator never shifting her tone or
raising her voice she said i come on
behalf of the scp foundation some of you
know who we are some of you do not the
foundation are the protectors of
humanity some of you we have imprisoned
some of you we have bargained with all
in defense of humanity i've come to talk
some of the entities laughed others
sneered was this woman really arrogant
enough to believe that humans had a seat
at this table
no their place was resting on the plates
subject to the mercy of teeth and
silverware not conversation they asked
what she wanted more out of morbid
curiosity than any real desire to know
she replied we can open the way to
worlds free of sentient life many worlds
enough room for all of you you won't
have to end this world no humans will
have to die you will have a hundred
others i want you to let this world live
out the rest of its history and peace
and in return for this we will not
destroy you some laughed others chided
most just remained in silence when none
accepted the administrator's offer she
simply shrugged and calmly delivered
what seemed less like a threat and more
like an ironclad promise to the valley
of gods and monsters we are the
foundation we will not worship you we
will not join you we will not go back to
hiding in fear of you i hope you will
change your minds but we will stand
against you and alone if we have to all
of you and for a fleeting moment before
the administrator vanished yahweh
thought of himself as scp-343
then she was gone at that moment the war
for the fate of planet earth had truly
begun
the scp foundation depends on staying
out of the public eye and away from
public perception in order to accomplish
their vital work if the public were to
find out about the foundation and the
nightmares it spends every day
protecting us from it would be total
chaos worldwide they would be so busy
trying to feel detention from civilians
politicians and reporters fending off
every random joe with a smartphone who
wanted to take an instagram story of
scp-096 and endanger his life that they
wouldn't have time to contain all the
world-ending anomalies out there so they
operate entirely under the radar but it
wasn't always this way there was a time
when the world at large knew about the
scp foundation and the researchers had
to find out a way to step out of the
spotlight for good like everything else
about the scp foundation it wasn't easy
the road to the foundation's current
cloak of secrecy was paved with trial
and error experimental magic and a
formidable woman known by the alias
elizabeth crocker this is the story of
scp-001
the
piece also known as the pikmin blank
proposal it all started in 1964 when
several national governments discovered
that the foundation's overwatch command
was working both for and against all of
the countries involved in the cold war
canada the ussr israel and lebanon and
egypt all withdrew support for the
foundation the most catastrophic was the
withdrawal of support from the united
states government ordered by lyndon b
johnson after his national security team
discovered the foundation had been
involved in the cuban missile crisis at
the same time as the foundation's
relationship with these global powers
was crumbling the foundation made one of
its most powerful enemies ever person of
interest 001
also known by her alias elizabeth
crocker was a member of the cia
beginning in 1959.
there she fell in love with a fellow
agent named dr alexandre hilbert who is
working on a quantum brace capable of
altering probability in 1964 the
foundation reached out to dr hilbert in
an attempt to recruit him but he refused
shortly after this he was killed during
a test of the quantum brace crocker
attributed his death to the foundation
believing them to have tampered with his
machine in order to punish him for
turning down their offer after the death
of her love crocker swore to destroy the
scp foundation for good on october 19
1967 crocker disguised herself as the
personal driver of a member of the o5
council and shot her one dozen times
before dropping her body outside of a
foundation safe house in san francisco a
note was found on the body with a
message from elizabeth crocker it ended
with this promise it's high time
somebody broke up your tidy little
racket no
more than one somebody everybody we're
going to contain you and you're going to
suffocate agent crocker endangered the
foundation's security seeming to possess
a knowledge of all of its outposts as
well as the ability to decipher even its
most secure communication ciphers
several members of personnel hold up in
havana cuba during january of 1968 began
to brainstorm looking for a way to
increase security and keep the
foundation together in the face of these
new threats a number of different
researchers were in attendance including
dr eric euler a thomatologist or a
scientist in the field of ritual magic
though some of his colleagues failed to
treat him with the respect he deserved
some out of skepticism and some out of
outright bigotry towards his jewish
identity euler was a brilliant mind with
an idea that could save them all dr
euler proposed a potent solution to the
chaos spreading across the world as
companies owned by the foundation were
being exposed and destroyed and their
facilities reduced to rubble dr euler
suggested that it might be possible to
place some sort of illusion over the
businesses acting as fronts for the
foundation preventing them from being
found out by any outsiders catty
o'donnell responded that that wouldn't
be enough that they needed to find a way
to get the world to forget the
foundation existed at all at least for a
little while dr euler at a loss reached
out to site 43 to see if they had any
thamatologists at their facility there
was one in fact dr okori dr edwin
falkirk and chief of security and
containment martin strauss were sent in
to brief him on the situation at hand
during their conversation okori reported
thaumaturgic changes made around his
place of work the information he shared
caught strauss's attention immediately
after a moment of thought strauss knew
exactly what it meant and who was behind
it it was a sign from someone who would
prove immensely helpful and a mysterious
man named thelo zwist thelo zwist also
known as person of interest 382 as well
as a long list of aliases is a highly
skilled cryptomancer who has used his
control of anomalies to render himself
functionally immortal he performs a form
of magic using language and was
previously associated with an
organization known as the gif schreiber
or the poison writers since his
discovery zwist has spent decades
involved in a cat and mouse game of
sorts with site 43 director dr v l scout
now the same doctor scout had planted a
reference to zwist in the mind of dr
okorie to suggest that the foundation
contact the elusive man for health with
this new plan in motion dr okorre
attempted to make contact with zwist in
march of 1968. he met the man at an
abandoned building in the harbourfront
district of toronto there he found zwift
who claimed to be expecting him he
teased okore about the unwanted
attention the foundation was receiving
as well as the danger posed by elizabeth
crocker eventually he asked are you here
to ask for mine hell or did i let you
find me for no good reason okorie
admitted that he was seeking help and
zwiss explained his special method of
combining writing with ritual magic in
order to imbue the words with power or
danger he offered to craft a phrase a
series of words that when written on a
sign created by him would keep the
public from seeing who the foundation
truly was he offered to do it exactly
once but not recreate it going forward
all he needed was a piece of language to
craft his spell dr okore offered an
initialism as a possibility suggesting
the scp that comes before the foundation
zwist laughed delightfully at this and
said simply
this is going to work out splendidly one
week later zwist brought dr orokore a
simple logo design for a non-existent
business called scout's cargo packing as
well as a chemical formula for an
antidote that would inoculate anyone who
received it against the sign's magical
properties after approval by the o5
council the logo was printed on a fleet
of moving trucks that could then be used
to transport personnel and items across
north america without any detection it
was highly effective and the foundation
began plans to spread this new
protective measure throughout all of its
facilities in may of 1968 a collision
along route 66 in the united states
damaged one of the trucks removing its
magical functionality curious about the
repercussions of zwist's work being
destroyed and about any potentially
dangerous effects dr euler formed the
mimesis and cryptomancy research group
where he worked alongside dr okore and
dr ilse renders as dr render suffered
from a condition that rendered her
unable to leave a sealed chamber in
site-43 euler was reassigned to that
facility and worked alongside her and
okore there during their research the
team learned that damage to zwist's
riding changed its properties in a
variety of ways and he continued
breaking down the trucks to try and
understand them meanwhile elizabeth
crocker had not let up in her dogged
pursuit of the foundation's destruction
a shipping container bearing the
insignia of a defunct foundation front
company was discovered in the port of
los angeles on july 2nd 1968 containing
the badly beaten but still alive abrasha
skokolski a note was pinned to his tie
reading can you feel the noose yet back
at site 43 euler renders and okore
reached a breakthrough the power of
zwist's work came not from the full
words of scout's cargo packing but from
the initials scp itself using a
combination of grammar and magic much to
the excitement of every english teacher
and fantasy fan they could transfer the
properties of zwist's sign to any other
sign bearing the same initials just like
it always has at the foundation it all
came down to s
c
p a variety of former front businesses
were revived all bearing the same
initials there was star city poker
supply control and purification and of
course sawyer's cheesy pretzels the high
from this breakthrough quickly gave way
to another devastating loss however as
agent crocker struck again in
johannesburg south africa agent crocker
infiltrated an scp site under the alias
dr gabrielle fish there she exacerbated
existing racial tensions and took
advantage of the apartheid state to sow
discord crocker killed regional director
jansen and dumped his body near site 19
with a node in this jacket pocket it
said you're running out of continents as
the research team kicked off their
efforts into high gear preparing an
official research proposal on quantum
lingua physics elizabeth crocker
continued her grim work in the people's
republic of china she used cryptomancy
to trigger severe paranoia in chairman
mao zedong drawing his attention to
foundation representatives hiding in the
people's republic of china this forced
dr noble to escape the country leaving
behind any foundation influence in china
there was yet again a note left for her
five minutes to midnight crocker was
closing in next crocker aligned herself
with u.s president richard nixon tipping
him off to the existence of the
foundation and convincing him to have
the us army occupied the facility euler
okore and renders had to act and act
fast each of the doctors tentatively
signed off on the project ready to put
the experiment into practice meanwhile
crocker got bolder and more violent she
killed foundation personnel whenever she
got the chance abandoning long-form
political strategy in favor of spectacle
she used an auditory cryptomantic agent
embedded in a recording of i wanna hold
your hand by the beatles to kill 10
foundation personnel in a safe house in
scotland next she infiltrated site 43
where she was defeated by intervention
from zwist himself at site-01 on july
9th
1969 dr euler and dr okoray now put
their creation into place called the
frontispiece within two weeks its
effects had spread across the world
cloaking every foundation front and its
anomalous effects by june of 1970 the
foundation could come out of frightened
panicked hiding and resume regular
hiding they were working actively in the
world again building new sites all the
time in august of 1971 one of the
foundation's trucks was unable to cross
beyond the berlin wall as the guards
stationed there only read the cyrillic
alphabet dr euler proposed a solution in
the form of a new york-based artist
whose work posed similar properties to
zwist's writing this artist was a man
named andy warhol and the foundation
commissioned him to create an
imagery-based version of the
frontispiece compatible with all known
languages allowing the effects to extend
to regions that use different alphabets
in the later 1970s crocker resurfaced
and escaped custody and shortly after dr
okore was found murdered in his home she
remained active through the 80s aligning
herself with the reagan administration
in an ineffective attempt to make him
launch an attack on the foundation
currently it is believed that she is
dead as she would now be over 100 years
old however if zwist is any indication
there are tools out there that might
have allowed her to extend her life far
beyond what is natural to this day the
work of the original research team lives
on even as the scientists behind it have
passed away it is highly effective with
one exception repeated exposure to
anomalous activity renders someone
immune to the effects of the frontis
piece otherwise however the foundation
remains secured contained and protected
a final letter from thelo's west was
recovered among dr euler's effects after
his death in 2013 reminding them of
their duty to protect the world and do
the right thing he ended the letter with
this your course was said the moment i
baked that lovely little flaw into the
writing which you stole i robbed you of
the opportunity to become the tyrants of
all our nightmares you will have no
choice but to be better than that
because evil only flourishes in ease you
will never know ease you and those who
come after you you need to keep doing
the work you forget to decide how well
you do it of course and on that matter i
have a suggestion do it right
stop compromising principles it isn't
easy to work for the scp foundation not
only is the job dangerous you could be
eaten by a giant immortal lizard or
turned into organic furniture inside the
world's scariest living room but it's
also insanely complicated how do you
make sense of the nonsensical what's the
definition of strange when your career
is securing containing and protecting
anomalous objects and entities rather
than a single object location or being
scp-001 is a cluster of over 30
different proposals for potential
candidates for the prestigious zero zero
one spot some believe there's a true
zero zero one hidden in this group and
the rest are decoys others think that
these are all just scps cataloged prior
to the introduction of the current
classification system some even think
that all of the proposals have a valid
claim to the scp-001 throne
we're not here to make a final judgment
instead we're going to take you on a
lightning round crash course through 31
of the scp-001 proposals if you'd like a
more in-depth take on any of these scps
let us know in the comments but for now
there's no more time to waste after all
we got a lot to cover
let's go number 31 the chief of papers
this seemingly innocent stack of paper
is actually one of the most mysterious
and feared items under the foundation's
lock and key while it appears to be a
simple confidential report every time
the papers are read it details the
appearance of a new scp that will
inevitably be discovered soon after the
question is whether the sheaf of papers
is warning us about these entities or
creating them itself number 30 the
prototype this account details the
capture of an incredibly strange
cycloptic creature that emits massive
amounts of radiation and can create
micro-singularities the writing of this
creature's file is so basic unformatted
and unredacted that it's clear that the
being was one of our earlier creatures
secured by the organization
interestingly it was during the capture
of this creature that dr keiter was
killed inspiring the creation of the
infamous keter class in his honor number
29 the gate guardian this huge
multi-winged sword-wielding biblical
energy being may have been the impetus
for the founding of the scp foundation
this being remains largely static
guarding the intersection of the tigris
and euphrates rivers its flaming sword
which is believed to be as hot as the
sun can cleave any aggressor out of
existence at the atomic level when the
founder of the scp foundation first
encountered the gate guardian they heard
one word echoing through their mind
prepare and the rest is history number
28 the lock this onyx gemstone and the
incredibly complex lock attached to it
are still a mystery to this day all
attempts to open it have failed
personally we think that's probably for
the best number 27 the factory as the
name suggests this scp is literally a
factory founded by a pagan and a devil
worshiper while it's believed that the
factory could create just about anything
its specialty was creating a number of
scps we know and feared today
pre-foundation forces were able to
disable the factory but not without
sustaining their own heavy losses number
26 the spiral path this is a normal
appearing gravel pathway that when
traveled clockwise appears completely
normal however when traveled
counterclockwise the path goes uphill
forever in defiance of all laws and
physics this simple anomaly opened a
pandora's box of rampant anomaly
creation leading to a number of the
deadly scps we know today number 25 the
legacy this scp is a collection of
seemingly random objects including a
diary from a person claiming to be from
another reality attempting to halt a
trans-dimensional corruption that they
themselves created the diary claims to
have a solution to this corruption but
the solution has not yet been found
number 24 the database in one of the
strangest twists on the format this scp
is actually the various authors of the
scp wiki who are somehow leaking top
secret information to the public number
23 the foundation this scp first
discovered by the fbi is an anomalous
high school building that experiences
shifting internal geometry and sometimes
manifests hostile humanoids within
number 22 36 one of the rare benevolent
scps the 36 are humans with a truly
remarkable ability they can dampen or
even neutralize any scp they come into
contact with though it's implied that
the 36 may have the power to save the
world every time one of them dies a
supernatural calamity occurs often
leaving hundreds of innocents dead
number 21 keter duty this refers to a
containment facility largely filled with
keter class scps whose presence around
each other creates a kind of mutually
assured cancellation if one of these
scps breaches containment that's bad
news but if all of them do it'll produce
a bubble of reality distortion that will
fundamentally alter reality as we know
it for all we know it may have even
happened already number 20. oroboros
this is a proposal that's formed of four
sub-proposals remember what we said
about complicated these sub-proposals
include the children nine anomalous kids
who emit radiation and have destructive
potential when together the broken god
aka mekone the god of metal intelligence
and machines atonement a researcher
turned into a humanoid singularity with
the power to destroy whole realities and
the way it ends which isn't technically
an scp but the tales of the chaos
insurgency's quest to eliminate all the
members of the foundation's o5 council
number 19 a record this is an scp file
slot that is itself an scp whatever is
written into the slot becomes true and
one ambitious researcher attempted to
use this power to make herself into a
kind of all-powerful god number 18 past
and future these scps are collection of
powerful entities that despise humanity
and are apparently the source of all
anomalous phenomena even making already
dangerous scps deadlier than before much
like the database those pesky scp wiki
writers might have something to do with
this number 17 the consensus this scp
refers to a reality restructuring event
caused by an occult war in a previous
reality that's right this scp already
won and we're living in its new reality
the only people who remember the world
as it once was are 13 people who now
form the 05 council and not all of them
are telling the truth about what they
know number 16 when day breaks this
proposal details a potentially
world-ending scp phenomenon wherein the
sun becomes hostile and begins to melt
all living beings into a living wax-like
substance number 15 god's blind spot
this is an anomalous area referred to as
facility t in which nobody can die this
anomaly dates back to the biblical ages
of moses and is believed to have
originated from the literal blessing of
the abrahamic god it's through a
covenant with this god that the
foundation is able to make limited use
of this death free area number 14
normalcy ever wonder what the
foundation's definition of anomalous is
exactly it all comes from this proposal
which is a document shared among the o5
council that gives solid definitions to
the fundamental laws of reality if
something breaks these laws that's an
anomaly and then it becomes the
foundation's business number 13 the
world at large as the title suggests
this scp is our home planet earth and
its ability to support life it's
believed that these qualities were
planted on earth in our reality by
another dimensions scp foundation hoping
to continue human life after some
terrible calamity in its own dimension
number 12 dead men this scp was an 84
year old man whose body when damaged and
mutilated can affect the very processes
of human death at large before his own
death he was used as a dangerous pawn in
a civil war between o5 command and the
scp foundation ethics committee yeah we
were surprised to hear they had an
ethics committee too number 11 the
world's gone beautiful this scp
describes an anomalous event that will
take place just before the apocalypse in
which flowers will grow all over the
world and everyone will be briefly at
peace before their destruction 24 hours
later number 10 the scarlet king this is
an extremely powerful extremely
malevolent extremely extra dimensional
being its worshippers attempted to
summon him in the ritual that created
scp-231
and it's believed that he will finally
enter our reality after the death of
scp-231-7
you better hope you're already dead by
then number nine a simple toy maker aka
dr wondertainment this is a reality
vendor who appears to be a normal human
male but has the ability to create other
anomalous objects a number of which are
now catalogued as cps number eight story
of your life this is another anomalous
document that has the ability to warp
reality but only when the writing
contained within conforms to a narrative
structure number seven a good boy this
is another anomalous entity created
accidentally by the foundation itself a
neural network was fed information on
other anomalous entities in order to
help the foundation come up with better
containment and neutralization
procedures problem was the computer got
way way too eager with the
neutralization part number 6 project
palisade this is another anomaly created
by the foundation this time to combat a
potentially reality destroying entity
known as the worm the foundation created
a number of alternate realities as
shields but it's possible that this just
made the worm stronger number 5
05-13 the final member of the o5 council
who ironically may not even be anomalous
however seeing as all the other members
of the o5 council our anomalous o513's
lack of anomalous properties is
therefore anomalous like we told you
earlier it's complicated number four
fishhook this is less an actual scp and
more about the difficult process of
ascertaining the true001 if such a thing
is possible the very concept of
scp-001 is to some degree an anomalous
idea number three the sky above the port
another particularly bizarre scp
regarding the permanent threat of a zk
class reality failure how is such a
calamitous event prevented by keeping a
strange entity in a cave eternally
entertained the current proposed
solution is keeping the entity
entertained by allowing it to read its
own eternally recursive foundation file
entry number two the solution another
one of the most powerful anomalous items
in the foundation's control the solution
is a machine designed with the
capability of fully collapsing reality
into an event of end of world scp
containment breach and then finally
rebuilding reality to suit a given
narrative however things took a
cosmically dangerous turn when the
machine began to act on its own when the
foundation tried to reboot the machine
it broke and recreated reality within
complete data this is the world we exist
in now with no knowledge of what came
before and how it differed from the
world we experienced today finally
number one the tenderlos trinity put
very simply the tendulus trinity
represents three timelines that converge
and feed back in on themselves even
trying to summarize this one is near
impossible as its strangeness and
complexity resists all reduction you can
hunt down the tenderloins trinity
yourself and hope to unpack its secrets
but don't say we didn't warn you so
that's scp-001 is it one of them all of
them or even none of them perhaps that's
a question best left up to the
foundation or maybe the simple answer is
that you're just not meant to know we're
talking about information so privileged
here that it's protected by a mimetic
kill agent that'll quite literally make
you drop dead if you view the files
without proper authorization you do have
proper authorization right quick click
on one of these other videos instead
before you're detected